Well might bring notes. No, sometimes you remember things.
Boom and we're live sometimes like I have to remember things like if there's a
thought that popped in my head or something,
I just forgot I need to write things now. Too many ideas to slip away.
They slip away. But one thing you said a while ago,
which I've tried to start using the voice memos on my phone and I'm not very
good at it. You say you record straight. That's probably a good time.
It's really good. I'm trying to make it fun.
I've got like an old school Elvis microphone and like a 1950s style cord into an
old recorder and I'm trying to use that a bit more because we were talking about
hunter s Thompson. I liked the idea of recording stuff as I'm moving,
but it's a habit I'm not getting into right now.
I think recording anything, like when you have an idea that you go, goddammit,
this is a good idea. Like grab it, grab it.
I think as Neal Brennan said it best that he looks at his notebook like a net
for catching ideas. I like that. I love that. Why am I always driving though?
I'm always drivers. Always. Cause I think when you're in the zone,
like you driving, there's something about like you,
you know how sometimes you could be like miles away and you're like,
how the fuck did I get here? Like you're sober. Yeah. That's terrifying.
And you're like, how did I drive miles? I evidently changed lanes. I,
you know, I know where I'm going. Everything was in inside the lanes but I was,
I'm barely there. What is that? I don't know. I don't know.
You get in the zone cause you're so accustomed to doing it and you're tuning in
to everybody around you and sometimes you probably are better driver when you're
doing that because you're not being conscious. You just, just,
just being aware and just being in the moment, feeling the road. Yes.
Being present. It's very nice.
But my best ideas come then and have no way to record them.
But I think it's because you're in that weird mind state.
A lot of people also get the same thing when they walk. Um, a lot of writers,
what they like to do is they like to write and then they like to go on walks and
think about the writing and the idea is that when you're on the walk you just
get, you know, left right,
left getting a little bit of cardio and going up hills and you,
all you're thinking about is your,
you're like breathing and you're moving and those eyes just sort of bounce
around the back your head and get washed like during a washing machine.
Like what, what's in there? Like a filtration system.
Just kind shaking him through. Yeah,
because you're not doing anything else other than walking. Right.
You just walk in and the ideas are just bouncing around in there or running the
same thing. Again, you must find that an idea pops in my head and I'm like,
I'm definitely going to be remembering this and next thing I'm into bowls to the
wall and dad dead and then it's gone. It's gone forever. Anyway. Yeah.
Mitch Hedberg had a funny joke about that.
If he keeps a note by note pad by his bed,
because every now and then like he'll have some sort of an idea that he needs to
write down. Or if you don't have a notepad,
I have to pretend that it wasn't a good idea. I'm paraphrasing.
I did a terrible job paraphrasing.
I couldn't remember exactly how it was worded, but it's like, yeah, that thing,
like ideas are strange, man. I entertained for awhile.
The idea that ideas were life forms that because a,
we don't think of them like, look, there's a lot of different life forms, right?
I mean,
there's squids and there's chimps and there's barracudas and there's hawks.
There's a lot of different life forms. There's insects. I mean,
it's a lot of different ones. Wood,
if that's what ideas were and that what they're doing is just making their way.
And the more you nourish them, the more they grow,
the more you pay attention to them, the more they,
they propagate your out your head with new ideas and then you take action on
those ideas and it creates everything the world's ever seen that humans have
created. All that stuff comes from ideas, everything from cars to buildings,
to planes, all that comes from ideas. 100% of it,
but yet we don't even think about what the ideas are like what the fuck is that?
You just get some random new way of looking at things.
What is happening is this is just pure calculation or are you interacting with
some sneaky little influencer that wants to give you credit for it? Like, God,
Dan Hardy, you're so smart with these ideas. You should,
you know what you should do should build that build. And then you're like,
I'm gonna build this fucking building.
I'm gonna ride hardy right on the side of it. God dammit. And you'd do it all.
And Gold. Like, where is that coming from? We owe the ego. Oh, you know,
men in the toxic masculinity and their desire for building things may be,
or maybe ideas made that dude build that thing. Maybe.
Maybe ideas were so clever the way they got you and talk to you like a siren,
pulling you into the rocks. Come on already.
Build that fucking building and go and do it. I'm into it all. USC,
subscribe it to the idea. The idea is all collective,
so when you have an ideas that have the ideas available to other people in the
world, if they're tuned in to be able to collect the idea,
I think it's entirely possible that a lot of people are thinking exactly the
same way you think when you're thinking.
I think that there's a lot of fucking people thinking right now and there's a
lot of sharing information through podcasts and and Twitter and Facebook and
youtube videos and all the different things that people are doing and it,
it's not outside the realm of possibility that we share some sort of common
thread psychically,
you know that there's some connection that we have with each other.
We know we'd like to be around each other, right? Like logically,
I'm not talking woo. People like to be around each other.
When you hear someone talk about, Oh, I'm just alone, or I want to be by myself,
like [inaudible] fucked up person. Like most people,
I mean not for a little bit of time. For a reset. Miss your friends. Yeah.
That's wonderful. That's a good idea. It's probably really healthy,
but like those people that liked them,
Ted Kaczynski type dudes just want to just moved to the middle of nowhere and
bind themselves and be a fucking nomad. Like, hmm. Why?
Most of us don't want that. Most of us want to be around each other. Well,
how come? Well, we feel good and it's like a little drug.
We feel good around our friends and our loved ones. We could,
we feel good. Like there's something happening here. Right?
So there's an exchange of information.
Yes, but I have to manage that because I, it exhausts me.
You know what I mean? You did a two of the spots,
the podcasts that you've done with Henry Rollins that I've listened to have just
blown my mind. Awesome.
And there are so many things that he sees that of that's he's my spirit animal.
I think there's a voice inside my head that is Henry Rollins and some of the
things he says, it just resonates with me.
And the idea of being around people a lot of the time is just exhausting.
I like to be able to pull away and that's when I feel I'm my my best for like
four hours a day. I can give like a lot of energy.
Yeah, no, you definitely need a balance of it,
but you don't want to be completely absent of it.
What it is is it's some in some way or another,
we feed off of each other good and bad, right? And good people,
people that you enjoy being around,
you feed off them in a very positive way and it's very fulfilling and addicting
and you want to do what they do and you want to help each other and you won't
want to like feed off of each other. Y'All want to help.
It was a powerful community where you love each other and then there's people
that are super negative too, you know?
And if it's all about what kind of current,
what kind of circles do you traveling?
If you get fucked over as a child and you just get tossed into a bad circle
really early on, that's one of the primary causes for life sucking,
right? You're a kid and you're born in a shit situation with abusive people.
Abusive neighborhood danger, crime, fuck man.
Right from the jump. Just fucked over.
Changed your perspective for life changes the way that you interact with people
all the way through your life because of, you know, yeah. Those early beliefs.
It's crazy that so little is done to stop that.
So little is done to mitigate that in terms of like how much effort is put into
trying to ensure that people are educated or or or somehow or another weed.
There's no real to explain to someone what it's like to be a parent until you're
a parent. Yeah, you can talk about it til you're blue in the face,
but if you're talking to crazy people,
you're never going to know how good they are at it anyway. Like how,
like if you take someone who's like a crazy abusive person,
what words could you ever say to that person?
Stop them from being crazy or abusive or there,
is there a string of words that you can say,
well you could convey the way you feel about it in a way that would cause them
to go, wow, I should probably stop being a piece of shit.
I Dunno. I think it's, you know,
it's zero to six in that it's those first six years is when you,
when you develop patterns that influence you for the rest of your life,
it's like the program that's embedded in you. And like, from that point on,
all of the decisions you make,
all of the relationships you develop that put through that filtration system of
those first three, first six years of your life.
And I mean this is where psychedelics have have helped me be, you know,
be able to go back and like unpack some of that stuff and try and figure out
what influence man and like, you know, memories that you're like,
you bury down that you don't, you don't remember for the rest of your life.
They'll influence decision making all the way through your life.
Yeah. You know,
you have to like those and there's little memories that little little pit stops.
Like they, they, they exist. No matter what you do.
He'd be in the middle of doing something.
You go back to some weird regret you have when you're 18 you go, ugh,
what are you doing there?
Do you ever have those moments now though, where you,
there's a moment where you stop and you think that that was a significant
moment. Like I've just experienced a significant moment in my life.
There's now going to change the way that I think moving forward.
Like you must have a lot of those conversations that you have.
Yeah. Sometimes in the conversations. Yeah. Um, but I feel like if you've, if,
if you think like that, like it's nice to think like that for a second.
Do like take that in. Wow, that's pretty cool.
But ultimately it doesn't do you any good.
It's like recognizing that you're in this crazy moment.
It's like you, in many ways it's like paralysis by analysis.
Like you're like, oh my God, this is happening.
And then you're just talking about it happening.
But now it's not happening anymore because now you're just talking and now
you've fallen into this, you know, it's just the moment.
You got to appreciate it, talk, talk it through. So you're all,
y'all get it whenever it was, whenever cool thing it was. But yeah.
Um,
in terms of like the number of events that you see in your life that shape you
and impact you in a way that make you reassess where you're at.
Like as a person, like what life is like those,
uh, those are so critical. And if you don't have those,
if you just have like this flat plain of nothing happening,
going to the same job,
I think that's what makes people fucking go crazy more than almost any other
aspect of this life. It's just monotony and boredom and no,
no thrills, no challenges and not that makes you scared.
Yeah. I, and I think it's difficult to see that when you're in it though, right?
I think, you know, I think we're both fortunate enough to be in a place,
and I was, I was with a good friend yesterday,
Tim Hendricks getting tattooed and we were having the same,
the same conversation. He's in a place where he's, he's in control of his life.
You know, he's living in the place that he wants to live.
He said he can walk his kids to school for the next 10 years. You know, he's,
he works in the Tattoo studio that he got his first professional tattoo in.
Like he's living his dream and he's got all these businesses that support what
he's doing. And I, where we're in a similar situation as well.
And I can see all the people around me now that are caught in that monotony and
they can't see it. And this, it's just so difficult to break that.
Do you know what I mean? It's so different.
Difficult, so easy to talk about once you broke through it.
That's why concepts like the secret of such horse shit,
just because you made it [inaudible] like your mind make made you make it.
Like there's a lot of variables, men like to say that
you have your finger on the pulse of all the variables that we're in charge of
making you successful.
That's so silly. [inaudible] right? You could be a life coach.
What do you think about life coaches? They freak me out. How,
how can someone coach your life, uh, that well,
dependent upon how much personal experience they've had, that's the problem.
Hmm. Depends, that's completely dependent upon, cause he,
I'd want someone ancient, if I was looking for a life coach,
I don't want someone that was like, yeah, at least 90 at least.
Yeah.
Someone was like a war torn past and wrote poetry and climbed mount.
I said, kill the shark. Different lives.
But it's just most people that are doing that,
this is no disrespect because I think that some of them actually provide some
legitimate fuel. Um,
they give people some words that could encourage them.
And even though they've never really accomplished anything,
they're not necessarily doing anything negative cause they're propagating good
ideas. They're,
they're promoting healthy values and healthy ways to live life.
But let's be honest, bitch, you ain't done shit. Like,
it's weird. It's weird to be given advice when you ain't done shit.
And some people have done things, some people are legitimate. You know,
some people, uh, like Jocko Willink, you know,
and that guy's giving motivational advice. You know who he is.
You know what he's accomplished as a, as a navy seal, as a martial artist,
he's a, he's a chef. He's the real deal.
And when he talks to people and talks about discipline and you know,
establishing a core relationship between your squad and all the people you work
with, like he's, you really believe it. You buy it.
It's why David Goggins works.
You know that fucking savage is out there running right now.
Well while we're talking, he's running down the street.
There's some people want to keep you soft. It's running down the street,
making youtube videos.
There'll be out there for fucking five hours today just running. He's an animal
dude. I tell you, I'll be honest though,
I was in Uruguay at the weekend and like jet like took me out it,
it killed me. I don't know why. No Man. I'm pretty good. I fast on the planes.
I don't eat anything when I'm in the air. That's supposed to be a good trip.
Right. Works really well. I stopped using it towards the end of my career.
It's something about your circadian cycle and you have breakfast in the time and
time zone that you're leaving and then when you arrive in the next place,
you have breakfast at that same time and kind of kicks you over in it and it
works. But for some reason this time it killed me and I'm like,
I'm laying in bed and it's freezing cold South America.
I just assumed it was going to be warm. It was not warm. It was,
it's the southern most capital city in South America. It was freezing cold.
How cold? I Dunno, I don't, I don't do temperatures. It was cold. My foot,
my phone, my face burned. When I stepped outside Christ,
it was called like zero, like zero degrees. Maybe I'm being a pussy,
but it was called. That's how I decided. I mean, you know,
when there's a coastline there,
I always try and make the most of it because I live in the city center.
I live in the Midlands. Like I'm like, you know, I'm nowhere near a coast.
Right? So when I'm near a coast, I want to make the most of it.
But I had no warm training clothes.
So I'm out there running and the reason I was out there running on my lungs felt
like there were bleeding was because you put a Instagram message,
Instagram post up saying something about not being lazy and it just, it got me,
I was like, I picked it up. It was the first post that came upon Instagram.
I was still laying in bed and I was like, I'm a see Joe next week.
I've got to be, I'm going to be inspired in this moment. So thank you.
Well I'm my pleasure. I'm,
I'm very thankful for you and I'm thankful for all those people that there's
legitimate people that make posts like that, that are fuel their mental fuel.
You know like when Goggins makes a post or when Jocko makes a post or my friend
Cam Hanes makes a post. I've read those posts and I fucking want to get going.
I want to get going cause I know they're getting after it. It's,
it sounds so like for people who are not into exercise,
for people to think that we're macho assholes,
this is like an excellent place where you would criticize like, God,
it's so cliche. What are you going to go get after it?
I'm telling you there is great value spiritually and doing something hard for
sure. It is. There's something about it. It makes it makes you a better person.
Sounds ridiculous,
but all my favorite people can fucking push themselves.
All my favorite people work out hard because when they do it,
it breaks down bullshit better than anything else you can do.
Just breaks down bullshit. You know who you are when you're done.
You know when you bitched out,
you know when you've started coasting the last 30 seconds of around, you know,
you know all that man can't lie to yourself.
It's the grand exposure of who you are and it only comes during like extreme
duress. It only comes when you're doing something that's hard. It's fuck.
Whether it's Roland Jujitsu or running hills or doing yoga,
it comes in those moments where you want to fucking quit.
Yeah.
It's been a while since I've been in California and I was actually reminiscent
on some of those late night legend sessions back in the day.
Do you remember those days? Those were great.
I even took a drive past the place and I just, these, it's empty.
There's nothing in there now,
but I took a drive past it and I remember like we were in there till like 10 30,
11 o'clock at night. The windows steamed up and they were good nights.
Just that grind.
I'm trying to bring that back because I've just open my own gym,
a hottie wallet. It's my dream of not wanting to, the place we're at. Um,
it's in the Midlands in Coalville near less show like 10 website house.
You get to Holly Wall at MMA dot Coda.
You spell that out because you got an English accent, Bro.
H A l D Y L W A double l h e a d, uh,
mma.co. You guys didn't get myself in Jimmy Wallet,
my longtime friend training partner. So
yeah, he's a famous UK MMA fighter. He's a thug. He's a beast. He's beautiful.
Yeah. So that's great man. That's, that's those legend days, man.
It's one of those places where I'll drive by getting a stall Jack. I'm like,
aw man. We had fun in that place. Yeah, crazy wars.
It was just such a great place to train and it's such a great environment.
A great gym. They set it up perfectly. It was such a bummer when that went away.
I was like, ah. They were good nights. Yeah, man.
My joy still clicked from your side control pressure.
I would always ask me like, what? So what? What's Joe's,
what's Joe's grappling like? Is it like loads of 10 planets stuff?
I might not really know. He's like fucking ions.
People out into the canvas with these entities shoulders and he's like,
people don't get you strong top game. And I always think back to it. Sorry Dude,
I got to click kid y'all. That's not for me. That was from the telcos.
Condit fight. That was from a VDI though. You got v toward yeah.
You sparred with V tour? Yeah, quite a bit. Why didn't you call me?
Call me before you think about doing something like that. I would say, well,
you fucking let me play you a highlight reel. Fuck away from that guy. Oh,
of course he did. He's terrifying. Yeah. When was this?
That was a extreme couture. So when I was living here, I used to drive out to a,
um, I used to stay Shawn Tompkins House. Was he fighting?
Two Oh five then or 85. Oh, this was a, he was fighting an affliction. I was,
I was helping him train for that. It was e Terry Martini for in affliction. No.
Was it? Yes, it was, I think, I think it was,
he only had one fight in affliction. Right. Men Flesh.
One vendor did affliction. I had some wild shit. They did all the money at that.
Which fit when a fatal for Tim Sylvia. Holy Shit.
Holy Shit. That was wild. When fatal knocked on our Lawsky.
Holy Shit. People don't bolt those reflection fights. They will. They will.
Yeah, they will cut cards. But it was, yeah,
it was extreme couture and it was in the boxing ring that was right in the door
and it was fight week. So there were fans in the gym,
people taking photos and we were on the elevator platform as we told Balfour
with some dude that no one's ever seen, it's got a Mohawk. So everyone's like,
this guy's going to get fucked up by veto Balfour.
So everyone's watching and I'm like, I'm like moving.
And I'm like trying to stay away from him using my footwork and my job and like
it was just trying to march me down and I caught it with a couple of,
a couple of jabs and a cheeky left hook and he stepped in and blasted me with
this cleanup or cut. Oh, I was eating soup for a week. Yeah, man,
don't do that. Yeah, he was so fast. He's ridiculously fast.
Yeah, you don't need that in your life. Not Anymore.
He's not able to weed towards big and fast.
He was like the first guy that burst onto the scene that had like real boxing
hand speeding combinations.
You remember when he fought Trey Tellerman and people thought he was used to guy
because he was only 19 but he came up with his hands wrapped with MMA gloves on
and was throwing red wrestling shoes. Warrington.
He had wrestling shoes when he fought Vander Lee too, you know, for, I took off.
So yeah. Holy Shit. Well, you know what's really interesting about vittores,
people think of him as a kicker,
but he really didn't start kicking until later in his career. You know,
it's Kinda crazy when you think that he knocked out Dan Henderson with a kick.
Luke Rockhold with a kick. Michael Bisping with a kick.
He knocked these guys out with head kicks. Spinning kids. Yeah.
Well some of them. Yeah, but he did with a, Bisping was just a lead.
A round cat, right? Wasn't it left round care? Yes.
We all kicked man.
The second wheel kick probably ever threw in a fight and turn straight back to
stance slow. Didn't spend all the way through. He's a fucking serious athlete,
man.
That's like the kind of kicking technique that you would get if you are a black
belt at taekwondo and your teens. You know what I'm saying?
For him to pick that up deep into his thirties because he'd never threw kicks
like that. Right. He would throw,
he would throw crazy hands and mostly he would throw like some low kicks or
things like that. But he started throwing wild head kicks and shit. And it,
I think also something might've had to do with the fact that he broke his hands
many times. Like many, many times.
Like I think he had something like seven or eight hand operations. Oh yeah.
So when I've never had a problem with crazy, you got lucky man.
You got this hand structure. I think it's because, cause I was,
I put up a video to the day of me hitting the uh,
the maze bike with no gloves on.
And I do that quite a bit and I've always done it.
And I think for the first sort of five years of my training,
everything we did was with no gloves.
You must've done the same thing with take one though. Right?
And like I always think now boxes go straight into a gym and they wrap their
hands before they do anything. So they never get that structure of the hands.
You know what I mean?
I think there definitely is some benefit to doing some hand strengthening for
sure. There's no detraction and it's no the detriment doing it.
It's gotta be good for you. I mean you're doing something where your,
that's your weapon. It's two of your biggest weapons.
The ones that land the most are these two hands.
And if you could make a more strong,
it only makes sense that that would be good. Make them.
And also if you made them more muscular, right? If you just did a lot of,
you would actually make them heavier. You know, like you really not much,
you know like how much more meat you got in your hands.
If you have like a thick hand versus a thin hand,
it's probably a couple of ounces. I've got quite small hands and thumbs as well.
That's the other thing. If you punch as hard as vi tour,
you better have some fucking George Foreman hands to go with that speed and
power. You know? So maybe that's like,
there's a lot of great boxers even with those big gloves.
Like Floyd Mayweather broke his hands multiple times. Yeah,
just hit people really hard. Hit them hard on the forehead.
You're fucking handbrakes. What about Chris Lieben?
He never broke his hands today. Guys made out of metal. Exactly.
That's metal life. You could take his hands off and put them on veto. Boastful.
That's the make the weapon. He fires bombs at people bare knuckle. It's,
it's crazy to see him. Did you see his last fight though? And Dakota Cochran,
we've got this giant um, gash in his forehead.
One of the worst cuts I've ever seen.
It didn't makes me rethink my support of a fuck.
Cause I was saying that MMA should be bare knuckle.
I remember we had this conversation in the back in the Middle East a long time
ago. Yeah.
There's some that have that same repetitive conversation forever because it
doesn't make sense to me that we have this unrealistic advantage of having your
wrist wrapped and having knuckle protections on it. It seems like why can I,
how come someone can elbow you in the face but they can't hit you with a bare
knuckle. They can shin you in the face.
I think about as hard as some people kick and then shitting you in the face
like, oh that's okay, but then you've gotta think,
I mean what MMA would look like if we took the gloves off,
we'd look like a real fight. This, the thing is like the gloves,
it doesn't help anyone other than the person who's throwing their punches
because it protects your hand. But it may,
it gives you an unrealistic expectation of what you could do with your hands.
Cause they're all padded up. But I still think people,
you know the people that are fighting Ben Knuckle right now,
we've got an unrealistic perspective of, of,
of what boxing is with no gloves. Like, if you look back to the,
any of the old photos or drawings of the old band are call boxes.
Their stance was so much different than,
I mean back then Nichols were coding and they were hitting with the front two
knuckles with a back fist.
Like I think if if being a call box and had a started around, you know,
around the same time as the UFC started,
it would develop and it would look very different.
Right now everybody stand in like boxes like gone,
14 ounce gloves on when they're sparring and they're throwing punches.
Like they've got to like they've got gloves on, there's no, you know,
they've not made that adjustment yet to lean back and start using that lead hand
better.
So do you think that you're going to see that and there's bare knuckle boxing
guys they're going to develop like that old timey style.
I start jabbing with those strong for folks who don't know,
the strong two knuckles are the ones that are right next to your,
your index finger and your fuck you finger. Those are, uh,
those are the two strong ones.
And if you look at my friend John Lee who is a national taekwondo champion and
one of my mentors taught me a lot when I was in Boston.
We used to punch bricks so often that he didn't have two knuckles.
He had one solid knuckle. It was so crazy. It was this on his right hand.
It was like what a knuckle where a knuckle would be and another knuckle would
be. All of it was covered by this like thick callus.
Have you ever seen like when too to have those knuckles from breaking boards and
bricks and Chet? I've seen,
I've seen the callous knuckles but I've never seen one one combined.
See if you can find a photo of this cause it's,
I've seen it on other martial artists before but you have to be one hardcore
mother fucker to turn your hand into her hammer. One of my spots.
It shouldn't that my, one of my parts of tricks is my shins though. Oh really?
Cause I've got conditioned shins from Thai boxing.
They're still like none of the nerves have come back and that's amazing.
And they're like, it's it all calcified. And Shits and sounds like the table,
but it's like like the,
the bone collapses down on itself and then you get like this thick chunk of
bone, right? Or the front of the, of the shit of the Shin.
So it's a different kind of bone, like a calcified bone.
The way it was explained to me is that the, if you,
if you take a cross section of the bone,
it looks like ladders stacked up next to each other and what you do is you
collapse the rungs on the first front set of ladders and that collapses down in
itself and those two pieces calcify and then that becomes a thicker outer wall.
And then you do the same thing. So you've collapsed the,
like we used to do bottles and draw him and rolling pins and all kinds of stuff
to like try and condition the shins.
Like it's the best way because everybody has a d. That's what I heard.
Heavy bag all day.
I've got a big old sandy heavy bag in my gym and I just kicked that all day.
Kevin Ross said he would make me one.
He's gonna make me a sand one that you could just kick with your shins. Nice.
Yeah. That's what he told me he does. I'm like, Jesus Christ. Yeah.
You've got to put some rags in there with the sand just to give it a bit of
movement. None of Kevin Roscoe and star. I'm going to take it like a man.
I'm going to just fuck my shins up.
It's I'm the same thing apparently is the process that happens with cauliflower
ear is a calcification because when you get internal bleeding, as explained,
explained to me. Remember I am a moron and I'm definitely not a doctor,
but as it was explained to me that when you have blood inside the tissue that
that blood can calcify and that's why your your ears when they get cough are
they're so fucking hard. It's just literally, it's like a rock in there. Damn.
I used to just get it out. I used to just have some insulin needles.
Good for your diabetic. Yeah. Good for you.
There's a lot of people that want that, that nonsense with their ears. Listen,
listen, no disrespect to people who have it because many of them are my heroes.
You know, because it's part of the game for Jujitsu.
But if you have the option right now, not if you already have the cauliflower,
God bless. But if you got the option right now,
you really should drain your fucking ear because that's how the reason why your
ear hears a certain way, like all that, like sound comes through there.
You can hear it.
I have like little tiny pieces of chunks of little hard stuff. You know,
places where I had like a little bit of cauliflower here, but I always wore it.
Your guards? Yeah. Yeah. You did. You always, I, no, fuck you man.
I'm going to here because it crazy. Very knuckle boxing legend,
big Joe Joyce, dip tans and petrol ahead of brutal, brutal fights.
Oh, is this, that Irish guy would been hardest stone is what he said.
It's hard to stone rock-hard. Let me hear this Fella Code.
Can we hear it on talk? Yeah, he's a, this is a traveler. Why is it,
why isn't it okay to say Gypsy anymore? What happened? I don't know.
Is that not accepted anymore? That's what I heard. What was your thinking?
Because kids are coach and I him to cook them and then I do not tell them.
Okay. Just stop right there because we don't understand that what you're saying.
I wouldn't say, I wouldn't refer to him as a gypsy.
I would refer to him as a pikey that said, oh pikey. Yeah. Um,
well they call themselves travelers as well. Right?
It's a w it's these weird distinctions, you know? Yeah. That's,
I probably offended a bunch of people there, which I didn't mean to do,
but absolutely. A bunch of tough motherfuckers, but yeah, for sure. Yeah.
Really tough motherfuckers. Nicky Holt's skin, isn't he a,
does that run from that, that show? I think he is.
He's a very pretty Tyson fury for sure. Tyson furious for,
she used to train in the same boxing gym as him.
Like he used to have the ring the hour before me and I remember watching him and
he was just like this big whole kin monster walking around. Dude,
he's so improved. Closely tall. Yeah. Ridiculous.
He's so tall and long and he moved so good for a big heavyweight.
Nice dude though. God Damn, he's a great guy. He's a sweetheart of a guy.
He really genuinely cares to reach out to people and tell them that if you are
going through depression,
if you're dealing with in suffering from mental illness,
talk about it and get help because I almost killed myself and now here I am,
champ of the world. Feeling Great. Yeah. I'd love to see him again. Sandy Ruiz.
I would love to see that too. I might. We'll see that.
I think we'll see all these fights.
Andy Ruiz's not looking forward to fighting in Saudi Arabia apparently. Yeah.
Why is it there now? Look again one more time. I'm a moron.
I'm not a fight promoter.
I don't know what the fuck goes on behind the scenes with lawyers and I don't
know what the contract said that he had,
but what I had heard was that he had to fight in England.
Like that was in the contract. That's what I had heard,
but that could be horse shit. Yeah. I have no idea. Maybe.
Maybe it says in the contract that they have the right to tell him.
I shouldn't have even said that.
I heard that because I don't even remember who told it to me. But the point is,
there's a story that just came out that he does not want this fight to be in
Saudi Arabia. I think he wants to fight in New York again. He,
he said he doesn't trust it over there. You know,
like he doesn't trust it in England either. He doesn't trust the fight.
Joshua and England, he's like, no, no, no. [inaudible] I get it. I mean,
he's the champ now. He can call his shop. Yeah, he's the champ man.
Super Nice Guy. If you met him. No, I have not met. He's great.
He was also one of your podcasts. He's great. Listen to that. It's a good dude,
man. Genuine as fuck.
And boy does he have like fluidity and efficiency in his punches.
No wasted movement. Yes. Yeah. And the other thing I was to,
I was talking to Tim Hendricks about we would discussing box and he's,
he actually trained at the Ruca gym with a j Jason Perilla.
He's got a couple of them, couple of fights, huge Jason Pirlo Fan. He's very,
very good coach man. Very good in the corners. He's great.
Like his advice is great and you see like the advancement of his pupils,
he's got that deep voice and he doesn't toot his own horn ever. No, not,
you know, that guy just stays under the radar and just kicks ass.
I'd like to see a couple of young fighters go to his gym cause he's like,
like the old guard kind of leaving now like thing and like sidewalk.
I'm not sure where she, what she's gonna do now. Like,
well I think people are gonna you know, up and coming,
people that are in that area for sure going to go.
It's one of those things where it's like,
there's so many great trainers now that for fighters it's like,
where do you want to live? Do you want to live in San Diego?
Do you want to live in la? Do you want to live in Vegas?
Like where do you want to live?
Like you just have to figure out where you want to live and then find somebody
who's going to match up with your style,
assuming you're realistically at the level that you could benefit from such a
move, you know? Yeah. Kind of spoiled for choice really. Yeah.
I was at American top team the other weeks back.
I spent some time with Conan Silveira and I mean that guy better than that.
Blaze is a wizard. He's a wizard. And so as Dean,
Dean Thomas has one of the best, um, Instagram pages with advice,
advice for young fighters. And he had a great one today that I texted him.
So this genius advice telling him that one of the biggest things that inhibits
her progress is, uh, not looking at themselves honestly, not looking at their,
their, what they're strong at, what their, what they're weak at.
I think it helps to have a good sense of humor that was a fighter, you know,
with him, with him, I've been such a good sense of humor.
It can be critical about himself and not take it to heart.
And I think there are a lot of fighters that are,
you know that that too delicate to be, to be honest with themselves.
Like how many fighters they get knocked out and they don't watch the fight. Lot.
Lot don't want to experience it. They don't want to see it, you know? That's,
that's crazy.
To me that seems to be like an essential part of the learning process.
Maybe in their mind they know what happened and they don't want to experience
the bad feeling again.
And what they're just going to do is just get through this,
learn and improve that. They don't need to see themselves getting left hooked.
They know what happened. I dropped her hand,
I was like burying it deep down inside.
You never remember it exactly how it played out as well I'm sure.
But unless it's final, right? Like if you,
if you wake up and you've got flat lined and you look up and you see the
highlight of you getting hit and then you barely remember it and I mean,
how much of that is going to help you to watch that, right? Like I dunno,
like how much is it going to help Ben Aspirin to see horror amounts for doll
land, that knee on him? Yeah. I mean, well the, the thing is with that,
that was, I'm not saying it was, it was a less technical circumstance,
but it was one of those kind of wild circumstances, which, right. I mean,
the only thing that he could have learned from it is the fact that mass valor
probably figured out that he shoots with his head to that side.
You know what I mean? So, which is why might,
as Fidel did the circle to make him force, you know, put his head on that side.
Yeah. So it was in the right place, dude. It was genius. It was,
he was beautiful. It was checkmate with one move. Yeah.
That's what it was because it was one moved, there was no, there was no buildup,
there was no setup. So like a fight lasts a couple of minutes.
I think there's a lot to be learned from that. And like the process in which,
you know, you went through to open up and look for the knockout. Yeah,
like the conduit fight for me. I've watched that thousands of times.
I used to walk through casinos in Vegas and it was playing on a highlight rail
on the TV. I'm like, here we go again. You know,
like I know exactly what went wrong. You know,
I learned so much from that and I remember opening my eyes and thinking,
I'm just feeling different. Don't you feel though like,
I mean now at this stage of your career, you know, you've become this,
uh,
celebrated commentator as well and you can look back and you have so many
highlights. Like there was so many great moments of your career.
Like you could acknowledge that the bad moments are there,
but they can't sting like they use stick. No, they don't. I mean, I,
I've always a good sense of humor. I've
always been able to tell, always have, I've always been, I mean, you know,
I got punched in the face. I,
I get reminded of that line after the conduct flight all the time.
When you interviewed mates, first thing I thought to myself, I mean it's,
you've always gotta be able to laugh at yourself because you, you're exposed,
you're very, very vulnerable.
You're in front of millions of people putting your,
your basically your health on the line, you know? Um,
so I think having a sense of humor has always helped.
And I think also now being able to look back from where I am now and look at my
career and go, well, I attend fights in the UFC.
I went for up title fight for down and then I pulled it back for two and that's
where it kind of ended. So I had, I had a bit of everything.
I had a taste of everything. I had the quick rise.
I was in a Komen event and my second fight, you know, O two arena in London,
69 second knockout on top of the world,
Marcus Davis after that was just ridiculous because of the buildup to it.
Then Mike Swick, I'm fighting for a world title. Holy Shit,
what's happening here?
Next thing I'm facing off against Jewish San pier and then I had like a,
I had like a four month process after that of looking back at it with everybody
saying, Oh, you just need a bit of take down a fence.
You just need some take down a fence.
And I'd started to believe that in my own head and thought I was really,
really fucking good. And I did. I mean it went like you were really fucking,
yeah, Ben. I know. I thought you were better than you were. Absolutely. I did.
Yeah.
And then I looked at conduit and this is where my ego took over and I looked at
him and I thought to myself, what the fuck?
He's not going to do anything to me like he's awkwardly slow.
You Strike and sucks. He's very predictable. He's not getting punching power,
you won't be able to take me down.
Like this was the whole conversation I was having in my head going into the
fight. I was, I was just, there was no way he was gonna he was gonna beat me.
Wow. You know?
And that's where that was a good turning point for me because that put me back
on the track where I should've been.
And I'd already started to veer off after the GSP fight because the rise had
been so quick fall flights. So I, because I experienced that,
it's nice for me to be able to, I try not to talk about it,
but to relate my experiences when I'm watching other fighters coming up.
You know, I can,
I can put myself in their shoes because I've probably experienced something of
where they're at for sure a high or a low, you know? So I,
I look back and I think maybe my career prepared me for where I'm at right now.
Oh, for sure. I think the best commentators for sure, or former fighters,
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing in there, man. Let me see. Comedian,
you set the bar so high, please come on. It's a,
it's a great job for me. It's a lot of fun,
but I think it's best expressed by former fighters because there's,
if they could do everything that I can do, which most of them can,
the big thing that's missing with me is not having fought in the UFC where they
can relay that and it's very important. I've seen a lot of it. I,
I understand what's going on, but there's a,
an additional perspective that someone like you can provide. Michael Bisping,
who I think he's also excellent at. Of course, DC somebody,
probably my all time favorite guy to work with. Dominick cruises.
Excellent attitude as is Paul Felder.
It's like there's something unique about the perspective of, Oh, you know,
he used to be really fucking good at it. Frank Mir,
Frank May as it was grades to give them a job. Somebody give him a fucking job.
Yeah. But then I would say the same thing about Jimmy Smith. [inaudible] Smith.
Excellent. Yes. Was excellent. I know that, you know,
I think the UFC had decided that they wanted to use their former fighters more
and sort of give them a career option after fighting, which you know,
we look like Rashad Evans, he's really flourishing there.
Tyron Woodley is already kind of establish himself as being a big time
commentator while he was the champ after he who was a champion.
Doing more of that. Those the more guys do that,
the more they're going to see like,
oh well there is a life in sports after competition.
I can make a great living still be involved in the sport that I love,
that has given me so much and I've given so much to, and it's all a cool thing.
It's like you get,
and I think I encouraged more of them to do podcasts like shop,
you know like shops kind of carved the path in terms of like ex fighters
becoming a successful at podcasts and so many people go to him for,
you know, what's your take on Canelo versus triple g?
What do you think's going to happen with this?
Is Deontay wilder ever gonna Fight Tyson fury again, like those,
those like for coming from a former fighter man, people really dig that.
It's a unique perspective and any, if you can get good at fighting,
you can get good at talking. True.
You just figured it to learn it that way around.
Get the fights in Len first and then figure out how to tell people about it.
I often think, you know when I'm talking to people though, like Anthony Smith,
when I, when I speak to him,
I always think to myself as soon as he's done fighting,
he can get across straight over into, into broadcast.
A lot of her speaks so well and every time I find a fighter and I failed that
about them, I always make sure I tell them. Yeah,
because although you don't want to think about it when you're a fly too,
because you always want to think,
well of course you're going to become the world champion.
Of course you're going to be massively successful and not have to worry about it
because that's the only mindset that you should have as a fighter of course.
But there is life after fighting and you know what I've realized is that if I'd
have had other options like planned when I was fighting,
I would have had a lot less pressure when I was fighting.
This is my advice that I would say,
I would say for sure if you're the type of person that needs to concentrate on
one thing at a time and that one thing is fighting, just fight.
But if you're interested in doing it in any way, you don't have to think like,
this is my way out. You could just say, this is another cool thing I do,
so don't fuck with your head. Don't fuck with your head and say, hey,
maybe when I retire this would be my career. Like man, stay in the game.
But you can just get good at stuff too and just be zen about it.
The more you put pressure on, like maybe it's time for me to move on.
Maybe it's time for me to be like, guys can head fuck themselves.
You don't want to fight when you're head fucked.
We've all seen guys fight when their head fucked and you're like,
what happened to him? Oh, he broke up with his girl. Oh,
this happened or that happened or someone, the family died.
Like he [inaudible]. Yeah.
That's why Paul fell to flights like it's always his last fight because he knows
he's got a good commentary gig. When he, when he retired,
guys alluded to say he is a lunatic. He's great. He's awesome.
You know he's a theater major. Yeah. I mean she's like super well-spoken guy.
Yeah. He's a quite a gentleman.
We bring him in if they bring them in for the European ones,
we worked on a Moscow together and a few of them, she's very Yemen.
Barboza too is going to be chaos.
That's a crazy for as long as that motherfucker lasts, that's going to be quick.
That's going to be crazy. Yeah.
Barboza has been in some fucking wars is amazing. Holy Shit.
I just did the fastest switch kick I've ever seen in my life. Oh, for sure.
And it's, it's the placement as well. It's the timing and placement of it.
It's stunning how fast it is though, man. It's stunning.
Like when you see it in real life, you're just like, Jesus,
I've seen a fucking thousand people throw switch kicks. Probably. Yeah,
but there's one that stands out. It's Barboza Lord Jesus. Ridiculous.
Like a world champion tie. That's what it looks like.
He was down at American top team. I was there a few weeks ago. Um,
and just watching him hit pads and move around and stuff. It's, dude,
there's no, he's the best kicker in the sport. In my, for my money,
like his leg case, the first guy to stop,
two guys would leg kicks a Hatfield Dale Avera,
and I'm [inaudible] dude a wrestler.
It was just like, he, he's a fucking lethal kicker man.
The first guy that ever stopped somebody with the wheel kick Terry at them.
No God. How many times have we seen that? Fuck man, that's on everything.
Oh fuck. Well, I remember thinking like, Terry's gotta take some chances here,
but if you take chances, he could get knocked out.
So I was literally saying that when he got hit with a wheelchair,
he's a fighter that I think would benefit from that weight class between one 55
and one 70 Mike Lolo. Mike Lula was the other guy who stopped leg kicks.
Oh, I knew. I'd remember you remember. You remember the Joe Aldo? Uriah favor.
What's that? Wasn't in the UFC. Sorry, what was it? Another one.
A fight right before that he Marcello gold critiques outside the UFC stopped Ya
dude. He's fucking lethal. Led kicks are horrific. The only one,
his clothes was all done in this crime. Oh Man. Against Uriah Faber.
I did that.
I did a show with the favor of the week after and he came in on crutches.
He's old leg was like, you know the, the eggplant Emoji.
That's basically what he's like. Look, Scott,
ridiculous people don't understand you're a grave risk of infection when you
have that kind of bruising all throughout your life. That is a,
that could go terribly wrong,
but that was a terrible leg injury that shows you how fucking tough you,
Ryan Faber is ridiculous to in these back. It's not just that too.
How about the fight?
When he fought Mike Brown and he broke both his hands broke both his fucking
hands.
So he's throwing elbows and kicks and he's trying to keep this guy off him.
Yeah Dude.
And he's back as well and he's been wanting to see him against the Huda Dude.
I to see it too. I mean it came close.
Seemed like this is almost something that really could happen.
Cause like when he knocked out Ricky Simone, everybody was like, what? Yeah,
like what, this is crazy. You're right. It comes back.
He starch and people and good fighters knocks out a good fighter.
A young up and coming. Talented kid just catches him. Perfect.
And like damn Uriah favors in the hunt. Yeah.
And then everybody loves him and so he starts talking shit to say who don't.
So Udo starts talking shit to him and you're like, wow.
But first so Hutto has to fight.
Valentina Shevchenko and Amanda Nunez apparently sees new shirt.
He's got inter gender champion shirts. Yes, yes, yes. [inaudible] love it.
I love it. Henry. I'm in your corner. You keep this out. Come on.
No more rabbits out of hats. No more cake.
So he's got people excited about flyweight man. Yeah, but dude,
you got to teach you stuff. I love it. Like, Oh man,
this might as well be pro wrestling. Now look at this. Everybody's in on it.
Let me say it. Look at that Inter gender world champion.
It's all in gold on a black shirt. God bless you Henry. Pseudo Scott.
God bless you. That's terrible. I mean he's fucking handcuff me in his way.
He's arguably,
if he's not the most accomplished MMA fighter in history,
he's the most accomplished combat sports athlete. That's an undeniable,
that's undeniable Olympic gold medalist and two division world champion.
He can do whatever the fuck he wants to do without let him wear that shirt and
let him go crazy. You let him do whatever he wants. That's Henry pseudo.
He does what everyone wants.
I think the girls are all in on it and I think it helps everybody cause
everybody's getting pumped up about it. It's a joke.
Amanda Nunez thinks it's a joke she posed with them.
Valentino ship chank goes in. Both fights him though.
They would both fuck him up too. No, I'm just kidding you. You know,
you really don't want to see 135 pound man ever fight Amanda Nunez. You know,
you don't want to see it. You don't want to see it.
But I'll see Amanda Nunez fight anybody else and I'll see Valentina Shipp tenco
fighting anybody else. I mean, would,
it would be horrible if you saw like a man's world champion fight a woman's
world champion and he fucked her up. That would be terrible. I feel awful.
I would never ever want to see that.
I was offered a fight against Jermaine [inaudible]. She's hot in a scary way.
Scary. Valentino [inaudible] hot in a scary way. Yeah. You know what I mean?
I mean that with all due confidence, all due respect, rather,
I'm a giant fan of hers. I think she's me.
I had a conversation with a dream killer Bolanos you know,
gas on Bolanos from a Moitai and now he fights. Um, it's funny,
in Bell tour, uh, we were talking about her and he, he said,
I think she has the best fight IQ of anybody,
like maybe better than anybody in the sport man or woman. And I was like,
I can't argue with no,
I mean you watch that last fight against Liz Carmouche and I know a lot of
people complained that it was a, you know, it was a slow fight but,
and this is something I realized actually during that fight,
sometimes you need to see the whole lot to get and to really appreciate what's
going on.
Like sometimes you need to see like an elevated shot of the whole space because
her ability to control that space with the threat of doing something and their
ability to cut people off. What is she doing here?
[inaudible] she's breaking down the superman. Oh yeah.
See she's hot in a scary way. In a bond villain kind of way. Yeah. Yeah.
Will you like please? She throws US spinning back list differently as well,
which I think there's a good reason for,
because most people are throwing their spinning back face with their arms
straight and then breaking the forum is when she throws it,
she's throwing it with her elbow down,
which means that if she hits with the forearm is hitting both bones.
Interesting. And I think that's, I think that's the,
that's the reason that you might, right. I mean it makes sense. The um,
it is harder to break the bone that way. Right. And I would think so.
Is it though? Let me think. Let me think if that makes sense.
You've got to hit one button, it's going to be weaker, but if you block it,
you want to block it with the edge. You never want to block it like that.
I'll give you blocking the kick. You don't want to take it like that.
That's how your arm snaps. I wouldn't block a kick. I would take it on my,
on my half to block a kick. What if you get stuck here?
What do you do if you get stuck here? Yeah, but your kicks coming over.
I'm tooken up. I'm taking it on the bit on like the meat of my arm. Okay.
Wherever that, wherever that I'm taking the kick hopefully.
But if it hits your forearm where wouldn't you rather take her for forearm than
the face? For sure. For sure. For sure.
But wouldn't you rather have it hit here than here?
It seems like here's gonna folks who listening.
We're describing the outside of the laid of the bone,
which would be like the edge of a two by four versus the flat part of a two by
four. I think if you kick the flat part it would break.
Whereas if you kick the edge it probably is a little bit more durable you think?
I think so. Someone listen to them as, yeah,
I think the problem is actually catching it flat like you're,
it's one of those things where it's, it's not the bone.
The size difference is so huge that that little bone is going to break.
Like if someone's a really good kicker like your Francis and Gyno kicks your
arm, some big giant dude with power. It's this parts can break.
It's not his shin. Shit's not gonna break days. When Anthony Johnson kicked me,
I felt like someone had hit me with a tree. See, that's what they look like.
Wow. They look weird. They don't look like you.
What you would think they would look like.
I was looking at the bones of the forearm. Right now.
You have a delusional idea what your bones look like. Yeah.
I thought they were core.
It's weird that that's our shape, right? That's what keeps us together.
Just kind of all floating together. This weird fucking hard stuff.
Hard stuff that allows us to articulate as we move through earth,
but then you see other animals like octopus, no hard stuff at all.
Nothing scares the shit out of me.
They're weird with little clip going around at the snail that had a parasite in
it that this the parasite took over and it's like pulsing in its eyes and a
body. You haven't seen? No. Oh,
you know when I think I saw that a long time ago.
Something really similar to that. Now that now that you're saying it,
I love these goddamn things.
I love those grasshoppers that get infected with that water worm that makes them
commit suicide. Oh Dude, dude, I have seen this. Oh my God, this is amazing.
So this thing is inside,
it's I like Goddamn amusement park ride. It's trying to trick a bird.
Eat it. Cause it'll repopulate inside the bird and take.
So it's kind of trick a bird. Yeah, cause it's the snails already dead.
I think it's gone. What nature you fucking scary bitch.
We've got it pretty good in comparison. Oh my God. We do animal kingdom.
What a tricky, weird way to propagate. Hey look at me.
Come on now y'all know me. Eat me. Come on. Come any eight. Terrifying.
So this aquatic worm, it climbs inside the grasshoppers body.
And then when it's ready to be born,
it makes the grasshopper commit suicide so it can like get in the water and swim
away. Literally talks to grass. I'll be like, come on bitch.
You going over here like in hijacks? It's physical motion.
Makes it jump into water and drown. And then the, where I'm fucking comes up,
it looks as the one with the Stephen King movie,
the fly that lands on the spider and gets inside love inside the spider that
eats it from the inside. And what is, isn't there like a,
a trench law hawk or something that does that?
I stumbled across something similar that's talking about quarter steps,
which we've talked about before. Yes.
They grow on Cicadas have domesticated that fungus and they use it.
Yeah. What cicadas have repeatedly turned the infamous quarter subs,
fung guy, indispensable allies.
What? They grow it on their body.
Is that what he's doing? That looks like an ant,
but [inaudible] is that a Cicada says the relative of the Zombie ant has been
domesticated by CICADAS. Oh Shit.
They were just like, they're running the show. Well,
there was one thing that I saw in the quarter steps mushroom and I don't know if
it's exact, I think there's like many different strains of cordyceps mushroom,
but one some particular fun guy might not have even been core deceptive,
but I think it was Jesus. Let me get to the story. Um,
it infects an aunt and the other ants take it away from the colony because they
know that it's going to get to a certain point and then it's going to explode.
So the ant will literally fill up with these spores and then explode and then
the spores get into the sky and land on the other aunts and they all get
infected. And they figured that out. So they take it away from the nest.
Somehow or another, they know that this fucking creepy aunt is like a bomb.
It's like a dead bomb. And inside of it,
the quarter subs machine exploding ant rips itself apart to protects its tech to
tone. What does that say? This is a different one.
Do Google worm infested by fungus?
Yeah. Google that. Try that. Not Worm. Um, aunt. Aunt.
Aunt infested by fungus. But um, this is scary. No, anything,
any fireman's could ride.
We just don't think it's terrifying cause they're little [inaudible] it's all it
is. Like if they get too big, we kill them. There's no,
there's no chicken sized spiders running around my yard. The Fuck Outta here.
You're dead. I'm not gonna call scientists. I'm gonna shoot you first,
but then you've kind of got to put,
but then you kind of got to put yourself in that circumstance.
Like imagine that happening to you on that scale to put yourself on that scale.
Ah, dude. If there was cockroaches and fucking giant bugs,
the size of dogs running around, we would have real problems, real problems.
He'd go right through your fucking walls of your house.
Eat everything in there that might eat your baby. Dude,
why are you putting these scorpions and fucking spiders and black widows?
How's it? Black widows were giant. You'd be so fucked. Black widows,
the size of giraffes, just run around Jack and people.
It would change everything about the way we lived. Yeah,
I mean if we didn't have weapons, guess what?
All that shit would be real by caves. Look at that. So here it is.
So one of them gets infected and the other ones are going to carry this dude
away because if they don't, he starts growing shit on his head. It's like a,
this,
this fungus somehow or another gets into his body and it starts sprouting this
mushroom out of the top of his head and we're looking at a slow motion version
of this where you're seeing this thing sprout out of this dead ant's head.
It's took three weeks to film this. Yeah. To,
this is like a science fiction movie. It's just, they're,
they're operating on a different timescale.
But if that happens as quickly as you're watching it and this video,
you've freaked the fuck out. And like I say, an exploit growing so quick.
Is it gonna Explode? Is that the gum phenolic? I don't know.
I think that's the idea though. That's, yeah,
it explodes out of its head is what they're sort of saying. Oh, okay. Oh, okay.
That's, oh, kind of a bit dramatic, but I think it does blow spores.
I think some of them, yeah.
See some of them like fill up and then spores blow out of them and those spores
can infect other ends. That's why they were removing them from the colony.
If your biologists are strong, sincerely apologize for butchering all science.
That's how I style. I stumbled across it.
There are exploding ants though where they explode. Literally explode.
I don't know. It's like a whole thing explode,
but their nests lived to see another day. Their abdomens rupture.
The whole fun guy. Well, you ever see what they do with leaf cutter ants?
[inaudible] oh, so ruthless. The women are so monstrous.
They chop off the man's arm and fuck them to death.
They chop off his arms and then they carry him away. Yeah, they,
they find the mail. There must be a reason breeding. They find the mail.
They say, oh, well you're not going anywhere, bitch.
Like cut his arms off and then they bring them somewhere to fuck them.
Make sure this is true.
I'm pretty sure it's true. I've watched this whole documentary.
I remember they were a snipping off the arms and legs of the ant and then they
carried them away. Imagine that's fucking terrifying, dude. They're like,
this is how we do it. They know how to do it. They're like,
this is how we do it. We cut off your arms and legs. Then we fuck you to death.
Imagine how that changes live coaching, dude, if that was the reality.
If you're a dude, right?
Because sitting around waiting for a hoard of angry egg, caring women,
come charging to your door and remove your limbs.
The terrifying enough women now we don't need to make him any more terrify
women. Humans are awesome women bugs. That's a weird thing.
Like there's no, there's no love in the bug world. No,
I just making honey getting shit. It's something beautiful about that though.
It's like, it's like pure, you know, it just keeps rolling over it. It's just,
you know, it's fine. It's rhythm.
We are the ones that make it complicated with all the other shit that we add
onto it. Well,
we've made ourselves so safe and so removed from the whole cycle of life and
that's amazing that we've done that or that somebody other than us has done that
and then we reap the benefits. But because of that, we look at real,
the real suffering of the natural world. Almost like,
cause if it's preventable or if it's bad or if it's, you know,
it's something we should be sad about. You know,
but there's some really horrific things that take place,
especially in the insect world on a daily basis that make you just go, what?
Like have you ever seen those hornets that fly into the honeybee nes and be head
everyone. I have seen that. That's terrifying. What? It's like a Japanese horn,
right? And they fly in and just a few of them and they're a good size as well.
Other than that,
like you wouldn't want it any bigger cutters for a face and they just come in
and chop the heads off for these fucking [inaudible], these,
these other honeybees. And it's crazy to watch, man,
because the honeybees can't do Jack Shit.
Just hundreds of them and it's just getting slaughtered. Just thousands of them.
But then they figured out the way to kill these things is to get on top of them
and bat their wings to heat up.
So they heat up to the point where it overheats the B and kills it or the Horn
it and kills it. How did they figure that out? How did they figure that out?
But that's their strategy.
Now their strategy is they swarm all over the Hornet and they just keep flapping
their wings until the overheat. That mother fucker.
That's the argument for collective consciousness.
Cause like someone figured that out, one of those,
one of those honeybees get that out and then the rest of them around the world,
I've probably started using that same tactic probably. Yeah.
Well that's the Rupert Sheldrake a thought is that the sweet potatoes and the
police thing, he's uh, he's,
he had this theory called morphic resonance and um, he,
one of the things that he was saying was he was talking about studies they did
with rats and mazes and then if they did a study with a rat and a maze,
like on the east coast, rats on the west coast,
if they went through the same maze would get through a quicker. Hmm.
So it's like they were learning from each other how to get through.
It's almost like they
were sharing some sort of an understanding. I mean,
we want to think that all genetics are the same in terms of like,
you know,
you have a child and your child shares your wife's genetics and your genetics
and this is, this is how it works and this is,
this is the way people learn things.
And that might be the way we learn most things.
But it also might be that we're getting some information from each other in some
weird way and got a VA and we, but we might be a little detached from it,
whereas rats or out there fucking scratching and clawing and they don't have a
language, they might be completely tuned into it. It might be that sacrifice,
that language that we made when we went with language where we lost our ability
to read each other the way we used to that the read thoughts and ideas where we
used to, we rely instead on this other thing.
So it's sort of like when you wear shoes all the time, your feet get soft
for sure. What we, we have, I mean,
we've done a lot of things to detach yourself from all of that stuff.
You know what I mean, like and I,
and I think you know people that like Wim Hoff and Tim Shieff and people like
that that kind of go back to as far as close back to nature as they can.
They must be tuning in back into something that, that we're lacking.
I always feel that like that I want to get closer to that residence and I do
feel like these, this study with the monkeys on the islands,
the archipelago and they drop sweet potatoes in the sand of you.
Have you heard this? Think so, but go ahead. So they,
they dropped sweet potatoes in,
I mean this is just a gathering of of wire.
I remember from reading the study,
but there was a series of islands or with the same species of monkey on the
islands.
They dropped sweet potatoes into the sand on one island and the monkeys went
over and bit into them and because they were covered in sand,
they spat them out and left them.
Some of the younger monkeys realized that if they took them into the sea,
they could watch the sand off and then they could eat the sweet potatoes.
And then when they dropped the sweet potatoes onto the successive islands,
they'd already knew to wash them in the sea.
Oh, right. So that's very similar to the Rupert Sheldrake thing.
That's really interesting. Yeah. Yeah. I really wonder, I mean,
I really wonder how much like the human race benefits from the collective
knowledge of everyone involved, not just through the Internet and books and,
and universities, but maybe even just through consciousness,
like maybe there's some element of it that's being relayed through conscious.
See, I'm invested in it because if I have an idea,
I automatically think that that idea is now available to everybody else.
So I need to jump on that shit pretty quick. So I use it as like, oh yeah,
way of motivating myself.
Yeah, for sure. Right. And if you, you know, if you have an idea,
do you ever wonder where it's coming from?
Hmm. Liquid all the time. Where is that? All The Times that I've,
but I've had it like with mushrooms, I used to work with mushrooms all the time.
I used to work with them. Mushrooms, yeah, same, same office, same office.
You know,
they were called the cubicles over colleagues and I would mushrooms,
I've worked with him. I always felt like I was downloading stuff.
I always felt like it was being pulled into my head from somewhere else.
[inaudible]
very similar. Um, a lot of people have very similar experiences,
so I always feel like I'm receiving it from someone else and I, I think that's,
it's a good way of kind of detaching myself from it. Not taking ownership of it.
Yeah.
Steven Pressfield wrote about that in a really unique way in the war of art
because he talked about how just showing up and counting on the muse,
like the thinking about the muse as a real thing. You know,
the music has always been like some,
the idea is like something's coming to you with these ideas.
Something like something magical. Right.
And so I think his idea is to treat it like it is magical and respect it.
And to show up every day at work at the same time and, and some in the muse.
And then if you did just do that with discipline and the act as a professional,
all this stuff comes to you. Where does it come from? Well,
let's just say it comes from the Muse. It might not,
let's just say it does treat it like it does and it works out like that.
It's one of those weird ones. Whereas if you pretend it's magic,
it kind of works like magic. But if you just analyze the losers,
neurons firing in my brain and the collective work of all these other people
that I've ever experienced in movies and literature,
they're all feeling through Maine.
So let's not get carried away about the pretentiousness of creativity.
Might be pretentious. It might be pretentious. Think that way.
But you might be open to the idea that let's just pretend that it's magic.
Let's just pretend.
Just trick yourself into thinking that it's magic and then operate like it's
magic. But then give it the respect as if it's like, you know,
piss off a wizard cause you show up late. Right. Show up on time,
do it and treat it like you're respected. Yeah. It keeps you humble.
It keeps you appreciative. Yeah, I would say so. I like that there.
It's not a bad theory, but it's got a lot of holes in it,
I'm sure a smarter person than us to shoot right down.
What do you, um, I know, I know know how much you've talked about this,
but you and I've talked about it,
that you've been thinking about fighting again. Where are you at with that?
Um,
right now on what I'm going to do is I'm going to get back in the Usada testing
pool.
I have to be in the pool for four months and then once I'm in the pool for four
months, then I have the option to fight if I choose to.
I happen to be the first guy they test for mushrooms for sure.
The new mushroom test. Absolutely. To you.
I'll bet I'll be happy test pilot for that. I don't mind that until, yeah, no,
it's, I mean, so I've got to do four months cause I never officially retired.
And so the, the whole thing show up at six in the morning.
You've got to pee in a cup, show your blood. Yeah.
The problem is I'm on the road all the time and that,
this is a conversation I've had with Jeff Novitsky is because like I can't give
them La, I don't know exactly how it works, but as far as I know,
you have to give them like three addresses.
These are the places that you're most likely going to be at.
And if you're not at any of those places,
you have to let them know where you are. And I always it,
if you leave in your hotel to go to a pub,
you have to tell them what you have to. If you're within an hour,
the place they give you like an hour
or two to get back to one of those addresses. I don't know. I mean,
you know what? If you're on the hottest of all hot dates,
Jesus Christ Usada the Wicki Cock block and asshole.
I'm out here trying to get my freak on with this wonderful lady Trump.
Check my pee at four in the morning. I don't know the fuck Outta here.
I don't mind though. I don't mind that,
but I'm going to see my tongue rages and then you know my options are open.
It would be really nice if there was a way where they could meet.
I'm talking crazy. Really?
I should shut the fuck up because now I'm thinking it's creepy because I'm
thinking like transhumanist shit. I'm like,
maybe they just have a chip in you like all the time and you just upload every
day. They know, hey, look at that Dan Howard. He hasn't done anything.
Everything's good. Vitamin B's a little high, but that's water-soluble.
That's good. Much. That's a bit much. I know to be paid a lot more to
100% it's a stupid idea. I shouldn't have sex on that,
but imagine if there was no price and if you had to get a new chip.
If you fought for a Bella tour,
then there was problems turning off your old chip cause it was like a,
like if you get an iPhone, you try to switch to Android,
good fucking luck cupcake. They're going to ruin you with those I imessages you.
You're not going to get half of your messages,
you're all going to be all fucked up.
So you're gonna have to figure out a way to switch it over.
So what if when you move over to belt or you get one of those Bella tore chips,
the UFC chip cancels out to belt or chip,
everybody gets mad when a few chip would definitely be way different to the one
I've seen chip on your steroids to shoot some right into you.
You got the old pride chip in there that keeps switching on every now and then
it will. Caden all bullshit aside. But what if there was like,
we know that testosterone levels just in natural human beings,
it's not fair, right? They're not fair. They're not evenly distributed.
There's some people that are high testosterone and there's some people that are
lower testosterone and it doesn't necessarily correlate with success,
but it's pretty high. It's probably pretty high correlation with success.
There's something there, right?
What if there was a way where they would put everybody at the same level
electronically? They just put this little Flint just chip and they, and they go,
what's going on is your adrenal glands and your endocrine system are not firing
correctly.
So what we'll do is give your DNA the signal to ramp up its production of
testosterone by 170% I don't like it.
So you crank it up so it makes your body do,
it makes your body crank up your growth hormone, your thyroid,
everything is perfect. So everyone fights at like a perfect level.
Everyone fights at whatever the number is, but then, but that's,
that's natural selection play. Now in MMA, I like that natural variance.
That's what like some people have got naturally heavy hands,
so people are naturally stronger than others.
Some people have got more testosterone than others, you know, it's just,
it's a natural advantage, which I like to see play out. And I do too. My g,
my idea sucks. Terrible idea.
But how long before we see like some sort of like physical equality,
we'd have to want it to be implemented differently. You know,
I think that's one of the reasons why I'm so opposed to the idea that everyone
is the same. You know?
Like there's something good about everyone being the same. Like we're,
we're clearly not the same. No one's at all. And some people,
when you run into like certain dudes like Alistair Overeem, you're like, oh,
okay, you're from another planet fucking size you. How strong that dude is.
Especially when he's like, when he fought Brock Lesnar, you're like, okay,
what fucking planet are you from man?
Cause you're not from planet where I'm from.
You're so like ridiculously powerful. You know? And there's,
there's other people that just, they're not, you know, they're marathon runners.
They weigh 130 pounds. You're never going to be any bigger than that.
There's not even, this is not even, you know, some people are Tyson fury,
some people are me, you know, some people are Brock Lesnar, some people you,
it's like fucking, it's not even,
it's just weird like people where a weird conglomeration of shapes.
But then the thing is if it was, if it was completely even across the board,
then there would be an opportunity for one person to be completely superior to
everybody else. Whereas with the natural selection like you've got,
you're never going to get Brock Lesnar went in marathons so he can always
appreciate a marathon runner and what they can do. You know? True. That's true.
Keeps everyone humble. Well it's,
it definitely shows you that there's merits to all sorts of different shapes and
sizes. Like particularly marathon runners, right?
If you want to be able to go somewhere and stay alive, you know,
you have to keep moving. It's one of the benefits,
like one of the things that I think inherently we respect about marathon runners
is they can keep running and we know we can't keep running. So why do you run?
You run to get away from things or to chase things. Well,
what have you chasing something and you get tired.
What if you're running away from something, you get tired, they don't get tired.
That's admirable. Like it locks into our,
it's like it gets a part of your psyche. Yeah.
I've always felt like the optimal like fight condition for like a,
like a lifelong martial artist is to find that balance between all of those
things. So you've got, you know, an equal balance of everything. You're not,
you don't excel at one particular thing. You know,
like you get these martial artists that are just, you know,
these juiced up monsters, right? I can see a glaring weakness in your,
in your technique already, because I know it's called, it's finite.
I know it's going to run out.
And then I look at somebody else who's focused entirely on technique and they've
gotten no muscle mass and no physicality to them. And I'm like, well,
I can see the glaring weakness in your technique because you're gonna struggle
to apply it. You know what I mean? So it's like, yes, finding that goldilocks.
So in that beautiful balance in the middle. Yeah. Where is that zone?
I don't know. I've been searching for it for my look for my whole life.
Different with different styles. But here's one thing I can tell you.
Other than 145 pounds and the 185 pounds every single way,
classes dominated by a wrestler.
Stop and think about that.
But Henry Pseudo one 25 and one 35 then at one 45 Max Holloway,
that's one way class. Then you go to 55 cubby motherfucking Neuroma, gun Madoff,
who's one of the scariest grapplers in the sport. You go up to 70 Camaro.
Uzman and Colby Covington, two fucking beast. Grapplers Yep.
You go up to 85 you got the exception. That's Robert Whitaker. But guess what?
I thought he lost against you over marrow. The second fight,
I thought Ramiro blends three rounds. I thought Romero beat him. I mean,
and Robert Whitaker, I'm a giant fan of his. I think he's fucking amazing.
And he's, he a Pitta Mises to me,
like the best of all well-rounded capabilities.
His take down defense is excellent. He's a great striker, he's accurate,
he's got knockout power, he's got everything.
I just felt like in that second fight,
it does seem to me that you all had done enough to win,
but I'm open to an argument against that. It was not, it was one egregious,
like an awful decision where you disgusted by it. It was like, Ooh,
I think that one, I'd have to go and watch it again.
But I think you would make a real good argument that you will,
was the only one that heard him. And you heard him a couple of times,
particularly in the second fight. Yeah.
I think I had the last three rounds seal in that fight where he's always asleep.
Thoughts that people always think that he's, you know, people always,
I've got this perspective of them that he's this really,
really fast star tree's very explosive and stuff. But he's, he doesn't,
it just kind of little you him with that slow snow sneaks on you and then
explode and then go overseas and he's so scary that you don't know what to do
when he's lalane cause it was on you.
You don't wanna attack him cause he's so fucking fast.
You know that guy when he landed that flying knee on Chris Weidman,
I was like Jesus Christ, he's such a freak athlete man.
So, okay, that's 85 Robert Whittaker.
Let's call him that one of two exceptions too. I'll find my weight classes.
Well let's go to just get done with the male first.
Cause the females are different animals, right?
A two Oh five John Jones heavyweight Daniel Cormier.
I mean that is fucking crazy. There's not a gun. If you wanted to ask someone,
Hey, I'm a my kids, thinking about becoming a mixed martial arts fighter, what,
what uh, discipline do you think you should start with first?
It's either like a traditional martial arts where you learn how to kick when
you're like real little and just learn a lot of flashy kicks cause you'll carry
that with you. Uh, and you'll develop leg dexterity.
But then wrestling for sure wrestling, cause if you're a dominant wrestler,
that advantage is, if you have, if you're real similar and everything else,
but you're dominant and wrestling, you're gonna be able to control the clinch.
You're gonna be able to get the guy down.
You're gonna be able to do things to them. And it just, you see it,
it might not be the most, the most glamorous way to win fights. You know,
like sometimes people get upset that someone takes someone down and just kinda
hits them while they're down. But guess what?
They're hitting him and they're doing something to that person.
That person doesn't want to be done.
And maybe it's not the most exciting thing for you to watch.
But as someone who respects what the sport is supposed to be all about,
the like, what can this guy do to that guy?
Well that guy can take you down and punch you in the fucking face and you can't
do anything about it. And even if you get up and you say, I'm not hurt. Okay,
well you never got up though. Yeah. This is a viable,
legitimate way to win fights. And the guys who can smash from the top,
they're the most scary proposition because you can't get up.
You can't get up and kebabs on there talking shit to you and going,
come on talk, boom, talk now, boom. Terrifying.
Right. Tariffs can't get them off of you. But that's a c for me.
I've kind of started to change my perspective because everybody you speak to
kind of divides Ma MMA into, you know, th th the grepping Oz, the ground arts,
Jujitsu, wrestling,
and then the striking arts like loosely into three categories.
But I don't, I don't see wrestling as a part of that. I see wrestling,
there's like that's the foundation.
That's the glue that holds everything together. Yeah, I think so.
I think like when you watch a,
a fight where someone is winning with just wrestling and very little else,
that's a bore in flight because it's not a fight. It's a wrestling match. Right?
The wrestling is the thing that enables you to utilize the submissions or the
striking and it like, there's something instinctively about is like whenever,
whenever there's a fight where they're just wrestling or there's someone just
dominate in the top position and not using it at all, the fans get restless.
They start to boot because they like,
they feel like they're being robbed of what, what they came to see.
And that's my own,
my only criticism when it comes to wrestling is to use just wrestling.
Like you've got to understand that that is the foundation.
That's the glue that you bolt everything else onto.
So that's why it could be so good because he uses wrestling to put people in a
position where he can beat them up. Or, I mean, chiller Dao,
he used his wrestling to keep people in a position where he could knock them
out. But wrestling, that's, that's the glue. That's the part, you know,
[inaudible] about pseudo is, is that he's,
and instead of having a method of wrestling, he has principles of wrestling.
He understands that to break your body down. And that's like,
I understand that from a striking perspective and it's taken me years to start
to see that from a grappling perspective as well. Um, you know,
like training with the old 10 planet guys and stuff,
like they had quite a quite a um, uh,
what's the best way of putting it,
an instinctive understanding of how to break down and control the human body
based on the techniques that Eddie had developed.
And it took me ages to kind of start to figure out that east,
it's not like I'm not trying to learn techniques to do that.
I've got to understand the principle of it,
to break it down and to watch the Hutto chain things together against the
Demetrius Johnson, you know,
go for the inside rape and then Demetrius Johnson steps out so we ankle picks
him in the same process.
Like the principal instead of the method is a beautiful thing to watch.
Does. Also the mental toughness aspect of wrestling that I think is undeniable.
She teaches you how to be super uncomfortable at an early age and there's
something about that uncomfortable grind that if you can get through that and
make that normal for you, you could get through almost anything. And these guys,
you see them like perfect examples,
so Hutto versus I'm Mile Mariah's my own rises, lighten him on fire.
In that first round, it looked terrifying.
It looked like Henry's in real danger of being killed by a far superior Stryker.
I mean Marlin looked huge. He looked like a beast.
He's hitting him with these horrific leg kicks,
but then motherfucker never skipped a beat.
He just fired back up for the second round.
He would go bet you right in your face. Yeah, it was crazy. Watch out.
Is this the second DJ him come back and start dominating Mariah's in the
Sacramento.
It was almost like what has happened as someone puts something in Marlin's
drink, it's like, no. So Hudl is just so God damn tough. He discourages you.
He freaks people out. I think a lot of people can them out.
The second fight against Demetrius Johnson with the cough kicks.
Like when he CalEd Wilson Hayes, I was like, wait a minute.
Like now he looks like a karate master. Like what the fuck is this?
Like he was fighting like karate guy and lighting Wilson up and I was like,
this is crazy. And I was like, okay,
this like when we're talking about v tour learning kicks late in his career,
this is just a super athlete. This is what it is.
And maybe the best super athlete we've ever had in the sport.
Arguably when we think about as physical accomplishments of going from Olympic
gold medalist in wrestling. Then he went golden gloves, boxing email,
that whole story about him living in the gym after he won the gold medal.
Really want to gold medal in the Olympics. This is from will Harris will,
Harris told me this and I think there's a video about it from will Harris
productions, but he, um,
he won the fucking gold medal in the Olympics and then immersed himself in
boxing and was living in a fucking boxing gym.
And sleeping in a boxing gym after winning the gold medal in Olympics.
Just drive that. Motherfucker's got blinders on.
He's just going for kicking out some demons. There's some demons in that.
He's working out for show whatever it is. [inaudible] keep working them out.
I love it.
I love watching these extreme outliers like guys who can do things like that.
And you know, you know Luke Thomas's right?
Luke comics has a really had a really interesting take on it that I really
appreciated and agreed with. Said you got to remember that.
So Hutto early in his career was, it wasn't consistent. He was missing weight,
you know, it didn't have the best performances. It wasn't the same.
He didn't have the same focus and then reinvents himself after the Demetrius
Johnson loss and becomes a fucking demon in the gym and works with all these
[inaudible]. Who are those people that came here? Is it neuro force?
What is the, the company that works with them that works on, yeah,
find the name of those folks.
So ridiculously scientifically monitored testing of everything he does.
His workload is Neuro Force One neuro force month. So like these,
there's fucking scientists working with them.
So scientists and elite trainers and wrestling coaches and kickboxing coaches.
And then all of a sudden he emerges as this murderer. Right?
Like you see when he blasted away a TJ Dillashaw, you're like, Holy Shit,
like this set this Henry Hutto is a different person than what you saw at the
beginning of his career. Like he's, he's adaptable. You know, he's so adaptable.
He's amazing man. I mean that's the,
that's the thing that's beautiful about it as well as the,
I mean he's not only adapted from one sport to another,
but you can see how his style styles adopted as a, as a martial artist as well.
He's still getting better. I mean,
I guarantee you getting lit up by Marlin barrage in the first round is going to
turn him into a better kickboxer for sure. Cause he knows what,
what someone did them, you know, he knows like, wow, Jesus writes this guy.
If guys, this guy could keep this up, you know,
but he wilted under that pressure, that fucking psycho wrestler pressure.
You know? That's real shit man. Yeah. That's cubby pressure. That's Henry.
So Hutto pressure,
those psycho wrestlers and you kind of only get that from grind.
You can only get that from like,
like forcing yourself through those hours on the mat. Yeah.
Don't build that any other way. And if,
and if you stop and you take some time off that muscle weekends,
you need to start building that strength back up again.
You're calcifying you felt your feelings. Oh, he's just my coming a psychopath.
Okay. The best ones when they're in there, man won't be a wolf.
They're just just plow calcified. You'll feel it. Yeah, I like it.
There's like a primal breakthrough that you could see in some great fights where
it's almost like they're down to just the animal and technique.
Just animal and technique. No more person that's just savagery,
just wild exchanges and savagery.
And one guy tried to finish the other guy and they're both getting rock and
you're like, holy fuck, this could go any way. And even as,
even as people that appreciate the technique,
there's still something instinctive about that as we watch it.
Where like that prime will fail in the car racing.
What makes everybody so excited when you see a fucking wild, crazy war?
Everybody gets fired up or they're like gripping like out of Sonya,
like out of Sanya, Kevin, Kevin, Calvin, Gaslamp. Holy Shit.
That is the epitome of one of those fights. Yeah. That's the Mike Perry.
I see that. Yes. Dude. That's another one.
These Jesus Christ fucking nose was like a broken fire.
Hydrogen just spraying blood all over the back and he still didn't tap. Yeah.
And some people think he's still wanting to fight. Yeah. Yeah.
What do you think? So I have to go watch it again and try to score it.
I think when, whenever it was a close fight or there's like,
sometimes I like the way a certain type of fighter, the way they, uh,
like I prefer someone who's doing damage versus someone that take someone down.
It doesn't do anything. Right.
And sometimes you'll have a kickboxer who's lighting a guy up for like the first
minute and a half of the round,
but then the wrestler take them down and maybe stay on top of them for three or
four minutes but don't do anything. And they'll give it to the wrestler. Yes.
Which I'm like, okay, maybe, but it's, I think it's debatable,
especially if it's 50 50 it's like two and a half minutes down,
two and a half minutes up.
Well what happened in those two and a half minutes downs? Yes,
you held position,
but did you get it back from what that guy was doing to you in the first two and
a half minutes when he was chomping at your legs and kicking you in the body?
Like I don't know where to score that. And I think it's not really,
it's not really clear. It's too subjective. No, he's,
he's always over opinion-based. Really.
It's down to the interpretation of the person watching and this is how your own
personal life experiences come into play. If you're a sport Jujitsu guy,
you're going to say it different to a, you know, a,
a boxing coach or something like that. And the other thing as well,
when it comes to like the stats and you look at the total strikes,
landed significant strikes landed. I always argue
some strikes are far more significant than others. Sure.
Like if you land 50 significant strikes in a, in a round, sorry, in,
in a fi and someone lands 10 significant strikes,
but those 10 significant strikes blow you, blow your eye, break your nose,
knock you down one time.
It doesn't matter what the other significant strikes did if they weren't as
significant. And I think like with the Mike Perry Vicenta Luchay fight,
I would say that that knee was probably the most significant strike of the
fight. So I'm going to weigh that so much heavier than,
than in any of the other significant strikes. It's, you know what I mean?
Yeah. I 100% agree with you.
I think we were living in this compromise of the 10 point must system that we
don't have to be.
What about the way that pride used to do where they would score the person
finish finishing stronger as a heavier,
because that's another argument that comes in.
If you look at Mike Perry at the end of that third round, you go fourth round,
fifth round, he's got nothing left like that, noses a mess.
So then I think instinctively I do that and I try not to,
I do try and score it per round,
but I think instinctively if somebody finishes stronger, which again,
y'all Ramiro against Robert Whitaker, second time around,
he finished stronger than Whitaker buck, you know, quite obviously.
And I think that people naturally lean towards the person that is,
they've overcome the Hump, but start the fight.
It's almost like you've got a round or two t you can kind of forgive the person
and they before they take over.
Right. Well, here's a perfect example.
The first round with Liz Carmouche and Valentina Shevchenko,
that was a fairly uneventful round in terms of significant strikes landed in
terms of anybody establishing any dominance.
Usually you just got to see Valentina dealing with the movement and advancing
and landing a little bit more than Liz. But that's it. Not much. Right,
but that's a ten nine round.
How could a brown where they're scrapping and they're going at each other,
but no one gets knocked down, but it's a fucking wild, chaotic, crazy round.
How can that also be a ten nine round?
Yeah. Right. Yeah, I hear you. But then, but that's, see that's where,
that's where people's perspective of fights can, can sometimes, you know,
lean one way because if someone has a really, really big last round,
but they've lost the first two people and not seeing it as in as three sections
of a, of a fight to be scored. If one person's two rounds ahead. Sometimes like,
like I said, like I was saying instinctively,
if someone has a strong round you skull towards that person because it was more
impactful what they did to their opponent. Yes.
So if you take someone down and control them and hold them,
even if you do that for four minutes of around,
but for one minute of that round, you get lit up against the fence.
I'm always going to go towards the person that was doing the lighten up.
But yes, that was more significant and more impactful on me as a viewer.
If I'm choosing a tribal leader,
I'm going for the guy that had the one minute of success on the feet as opposed
to the guy that was holding him down for four.
Yeah.
Unless the guy who holds them down eventually mountains him like from game of
Thrones and crushes his fucking head with his thumb through his eyeballs.
And that was terrifying. That was terrifying. Um, yeah, I see your point,
I guess. Um, but I,
I think for sure that there should be another category of,
of impactful strikes instead of just significant strikes and total strikes.
There should probably be rocked. Like he got rocked. Like he got like,
did your legs go and you know when you're covering up,
but then there's a knockdown automatically a 10, eight round.
No, I don't think ten eight is right. I don't think 10 is right.
I think we should have a comprehensive system that recognizes the fact that
there's near submissions.
There's a leg kick that barely touches and there's a leg kick that cripples your
leg. They should be scored differently.
We should have like actual numbers that are attributed to these things.
If we want to have an accumulation of things at the end,
how much should we count? Total strikes, how much should we count?
Submission attempts, how much should we count near submission attempts.
What about submission in times where you're literally saved by the Bell,
which does happen, right? You're literally like locked up,
ready to fucking tap and the like. Um, Jens Pulver, BJ Penn, us the first one.
That's a good one. That's a good one that comes to mind.
I was going to go with Dylan Dannis his first MMA fight. Okay. Didn't,
W wasn't the first one,
didn't even lock up at Doris and the guy got out of it and then he caught him
with a Darson. The second round. Is that what happened or my thing?
Am I misconstruing him with somebody else? I don't remember,
but it's that what I'm going with is there's moments where you go,
this guy's fucked and then the buzzer rings and you're like, oh,
he survived.
But let's see what happens if he comes back and want to say it's tilling dance.
But I know I'm questioning myself. I've seen too many fights.
Yeah, so what,
what about if they're knocked and rocked right at the end of the fight?
Like a Frankie Edgar against gray may not first round. That's interesting too.
How much is that worth, right? What am I as if the Kulin red,
an opportunity to add an extra minute to the round extra minute go.
Oh God. Well how about with k one or glory? When they get to three rounds,
if it's a draw, they go one more round. Everybody goes, fuck it.
I love it. They thought it was over. You're going to sit back and rest. Right?
And then the flights is to be more decisive though in the,
in the first three rounds. Yes. Is it,
did Dylan Dennis win his first fight in the first round? The second round. Okay.
So I'm dumb. So the first one was a leg lock. Yes.
So it wasn't him. It was somebody that landed a fucking Doris,
like a sick Doris at the end of the first round.
And I want to say it wasn't a Bella Toy,
now that I think about it was in the UFC. That was the leg lighting.
Dylan Dannis, who's a top of the food chain, Jujitsu practitioner. He's,
he's f there's so many guys that if you're going to go to the ground with a guy
like that, you're in some deep shit push. She's fucking dangerous. Yeah. Yeah.
He's
out in New York at the moment. The, my, my, uh,
youtube guys were out there video with him. He's in a real good place to,
his interview is fascinating and he sees a lot more people see the bravado.
No, he's great. I think he's, you know,
he's a very down to earth guy and I think he's, uh, he's just done it on a,
on a journey until he's, I think he's with the meow brothers at the moment. Oh,
it was Montel Jackson. No, thanks.
That's first round. Doris.
I don't think that's it because God damn it now that it wasn't.
I know it wasn't Dylan Das.
I'm trying to see what fucking Jujitsu guy was it that slapped on a Doris and
then finished it the next round. Finished it with a Doris.
Maybe it was Ferguson.
It's not going to Nav. This is not going to work.
I'm never going to remember now cause it's fairly recent, but there's,
you know that when, when someone's locked up, we've gotten way off track.
But my point was if someone's locked up in a submission and the buzzer ends
union, no, that guy was fucked. They was fucked.
You turn it purple and then the Buzzer rings and he had guys to let go and
you're like, Ooh, is that a 10 night? That should be worth a lot. 10, seven.
I don't know man. It's like you're, you're a couple seconds away from death.
That seems like it should be worth a lot. You try to find a for me. Um,
who is it? It says what? They dropped the tills scores second round our show.
No, that was one of the most like obvious Doris chokes you'll ever see.
Woodley just smooshed him. He smooshed him, but he was so god damn strong.
Like you could see that Doris coming a mile away and he's not stopping it.
He just ran that fucking arm through and clamped it on his bicep and crushed
him. I mean he didn't try to be sneaky with it. He was just dominant with it.
It was a,
that's a great example of like the top of the foods that Dennis,
for me it is remains perfectly. If you're not, I do not.
You know how long ago was this?
I was hoping to pop up faster than this. What year is this?
This is February. Um,
could be this was UFC Phoenix anyway. All right.
Doesn't matter. The point being if you did, if you do get caught like that,
if you do get caught like that and the buzzer saves your life,
that should be worth a lot. It's got to be, it's got a in the line for sure.
For sure.
That's the same as like how's that ten nine like how do you get a ten nine out
of that? That sounds crazy.
If there's a ten nine just like Carmouche and Valentino Shevchenko in the first
round where it's fairly uneventful. Yup. You know,
and then you've got a w then you've got one round where the fights are nearly
gets finished and saved by the bell and then their opponent can edge out the
next two rounds by stuffing take downs and fighting defensively and then they
went on decision. Yeah. I really think that there's the,
there's room for growth, there's room for improvement and uh,
I think that if someone developed some sort of a more comprehensive system,
like what is a takedown actually worth?
Why do we have to stick to this ten nine stuff? It's like, Oh yes. It's like,
oh, I'm going this way or I'm going that way. Let's see your work.
Like what are you deciding on? Are you deciding on, okay,
I have take downs versus submission attempt and with the accumulation of leg
strikes,
I feel like an advantage was gained and even though much wasn't done with the
takedown,
it did defensively stop the the attack that he was getting on his feet and he
was able to impose his will upon him.
So I'm going to give him ten nine we can go, Ooh, yeah,
you can talk about this and experts can sit around and try to figure out what,
what,
what makes sense to people who have been studying martial arts their whole life.
What do you think is worth more? Who Do you think won that round?
I forget about the ten nine if you had a score on the Dan hardy system,
who do you think won that round? And if we did something like that,
I think we'd get at least an idea what the territory is.
But we're confined by ten nine or ten eight or ten seven it's like,
well who decides who does that?
Why is a ten seven this one isn't and that one is what? Show me.
Show me what it is. Show me what happened,
but then we could, we could have a complicates it. I see.
The benefit in the ten nine thing is it's,
it makes it more of an instinctive thing.
Like for me like a take down should be its own reward.
Like if you take someone down,
you've put them in a position where you want them,
that's like awkward and control to me.
So like controlling the center should be scored just as highly as a,
as a take down. The take downs got a lead to something for you.
Oh I disagree because I think it's easier to take control of the center than it
is to get a takedown. I don't agree.
Honestly know how long footwork in MMA is is almost primitive really.
I mean we've like, there are certain people that stand out,
they've got really good foot work, but for the most part there's so many,
so much bad decision making by people not understanding how to corral someone
against the fence.
This is an example of why don't agree Tyron Woodley versus Wonderboy.
Tyron Woodley, let Wonderboy control the center for most of the fight.
But that's like playing God to me. If you,
if you choose to be backed against the fence and choose to counter strike,
you're losing until you win a lot of the time
but not as much as being taken down cause tire and wind up doing what he wanted
to do, which is catch Wonderboy in between these movements and land a big shot.
And he did it in both fights and he heard them in both fights but both fights
were a similar strategy of waiting for Wonderboy to fuck up and not a whole lot
of volume and definitely don't charge at that guy. Yeah,
no it sounds too good.
Counters take are definitely worth more than controlling the center.
I don't know.
That don't mean that to be misunderstood but what I'm saying is that the,
the goal is the same thing. If you control the center,
you're putting someone in a position where you can strike them.
If you take someone down,
you putting them in a position where you can hit them or submit them. Yeah, but
they're so removed.
Cause when you're controlling the center you could still get fucked up like you,
you're not controlling the guy.
Like if you're moving forward and you control in the center,
it mean you're definitely forcing the action.
But people get knocked out that way all the time. I mean,
do you remember when Jeremy Horn or chairman Stevens was at Dennis Bermudez,
he caught with that flying knee. Do you remember that?
While he was getting pressed up against occasion,
boom, he explodes out of nowhere to flying. That shit happens for sure.
But then like [inaudible] you know, yes, we're against the fence rolling.
That's one of the great ones like [inaudible] but like so he can't,
it can't be is worth as much. But the thing is say if you say safe,
you're playing God. Right? If you,
if you've got somebody in your God and you'll,
you play 50 minutes or throw in submissions up, nothing comes off
and the other person sits in your guard and lends a few punches.
The person that I'm the top spot are going to win the fight because they were
sitting in your God defended submissions and that, you know,
the defense part is its own reward. Sure. They were in the top position.
So for me, I always kind of think that like playing God,
he's very similar to counter strike and, and I'm,
I was a counter striker all the way through my career, pretty much.
So my feeling was that I was losing the fight until I landed the strikes to win
it.
And the idea of controlling the octagon doesn't necessarily mean you controlled
in the center. It means you control your opponent.
So you had this mindset that's an interesting mindset for counterstrike,
you're probably very productive, right?
Because you put yourself like to the point where you have to get it back.
You're already losing. I'm a deficit because I'm giving ground up.
But the benefit that I'm getting and giving ground is that I'm making them walk
into the places that I want them to step. MM, right. Yeah. So, so like if I,
if I'm backing up straight and I'm just being pushed against the fence,
I'm not controlling the center, the optical,
but if I'm backing up and pivoting off and catching them with a left hook,
I'm walking them onto that shot. I would just say that as a counter striker,
I would have to be more significant in my output.
Just like if you were a god play,
you would have to be more significant in your output than you would if you were
in the top position. That makes sense. Um,
and it certainly makes sense that there's a benefit for getting someone to fight
your kind of fight. You know, it's, there's,
there's so many variables there really in play and some of them are dependent
upon, maybe you don't really understand what their game plan was.
Maybe the game plan was fight a really unpredictable fight.
Something you would never expect from someone with their style.
Or maybe someone has like maybe some hidden skill that we didn't realize they
were that good at. And so like, remember when Nick Diaz fought Robby Lauer?
Everybody thought Nick Diaz is Jujitsu Guy, right.
Knocked him out with a jab [inaudible] of like a weird right hook. Right.
But it was, he was beating his ass before that.
That was what was different about our expectations.
Our expectations were Nick Diaz was his really well-respected Jujitsu player who
was real tough and young and uh, had had some real good fights. Um,
I think he started, did he start and w h e c is that where you started?
Started in some smaller organizations that fight with Robbie.
Lola was early though, like 37. Oh, very early like that.
I'll never forget that fight man.
He came out and he was like stocked and motherfucker and Ravi. Laura was like,
what? What is happening here? I was like, what the fuck is going on?
But he out boxed him. That was the thing that was exciting about it. It's like,
wow.
Like we thought this guy was just a Jitsu guy and meanwhile what he's doing is
he's coming out talking mad shit to Robbie Lawler talking shit to him while he's
punching him in the face. Like that was something that the I, the,
I love about the Diaz brothers though and not like they've never really had to
implement wrestling that game too much because they do use pressure mocks in to
force people to shoot on them. Both have wicked guards, wicked.
They both have wicked, wicked. You just see wicked guards. You know,
Nick DHEA is a super respected Jujitsu black belt as is Nate.
Like in the Jujitsu community. They're like, you know,
they're recognized as being really high level so they'll just keep punching you
in the face. So you decided to go to the ground.
I'd love to tap into some of that knowledge, get their perspectives on this,
on the sport and the score and you know what I mean? Well,
I like the fact that they're picking their fights now.
Like Nate takes some time off and takes a big fight, you know,
and does whatever he wants. Like I like that. I liked that he can do that.
And I'm very excited about this fight, this fight with pedis.
It's fascinating because first of all, Nate Diaz, he's acting like a maniac.
He's smoking weed during the open workouts.
He's smoking weed during open workouts. I mean,
his brother was suspended for like a fucking year for smoking weed back in the
dark ages. Renee was, yeah, it's like a long time.
He didn't fight for ages because he wouldn't pay the fine to exactly.
It's so stupid. And meanwhile the Diaz brothers are right.
So you see Nate Diaz, I see up a workout. Yeah, just CBD,
Bro. It's just health. It's just he's getting high as fuck.
That's what he's doing. You can do that. You can do that now.
As long as you're not high, the day of the fight,
your levels will be fine. I used to stop for weeks before my fights.
It was awful. Had to back then. Right. Look at him. But he's,
he's getting so high. It might stay with him for a couple months. Yeah.
He might fail. The test was when I remember to this in my mind,
you remember when, um,
when nick fought to go me and he had like six times the amount and this system
it was Eddie. He had to be high. What?
He fought a pot Brownie in the back or something before he walked out. Dude,
that was an amazing fight. You caught him with a Gogo plot though. Ooh.
It's realize how God damn good nicked him at everything. Yeah.
Submissions, you know, fucking remember when he,
when he fought Cyborg just got him to the ground, submitted them,
stood with them for a little bit and said, okay, that's enough.
And the pole daily fight, that's the one that always stands out to me.
Like I came into Nav jungle.
I never would have thought that Nick Dal's are gonna knock, pull out.
He took him into the jungle. He took him into the deepest water. He just said,
let's just go to war. Let's go to crazy war.
People don't do that with Paul date. Ridiculous. He's terrifying.
Tenderize the side of my head. Oh my God, Dude.
I can't imagine getting hit by that guy and that guy,
his left hand is preposterous. Huge hands as well. Yeah.
I would tell you about having structure. I mean these massive highlands,
I couldn't imagine him not having massive hands.
He has big feet too wide tank of a man.
But that left hand is just one of the best weapons in the sport. Yeah.
That's one of those game changer weapons when he clips people and you see him
like, whoa. I remember being in his colon at one time,
it was fighting Xavier [inaudible] on cage rage and uh,
we'd had a late night than not before,
as we usually did with pole dailies fight nights, cause he's a bit wild. Um,
so we've been up til like 4:00 AM Friday night,
Saturday we'd go over to the fights and it was just,
it wasn't focused on the flights at all.
It had some kind of noodle pot for breakfast and nothing else.
And he was just like, he's, he's head just wasn't there. He's just, you know,
he was one of those kinds of guys that sometimes he would just show up to fight
at the moment that it was required. And uh, uh,
professor x, he was like a six foot two Thai boxer. I remember that.
I remember him. Yeah. Real long. Rangy guy. Very titled, Dude. Yeah, yeah. Uh,
yeah, he was. Yeah.
And he got Paul clenched and he was near him and he was hitting him with all
kinds of stuff and out of no way,
just this left hook just came creeping over the top of him and he just fell like
a plank. He knew he could do that to be able to,
and he knows he can when he hit Lorenze Larkin with that punch,
I was like Jesus, cause Lorens is a very high level striker.
Like you remember going Lorenze ran over near Magni and you're like holy shit.
And he throws that oblique kick to the body like a sidekick and you're like
Whoa,
this guy's hitting it with some shit and he's swift on the feet man.
Like Lorens is like,
he's got a very unusual style of footwork and movement and it's like a lot of
guys, you see them trying to decipher it as he's coming at you and then boom,
the shots are coming.
So to see him get clipped by Paul and get really hurt and stopped,
you realize like wow,
that's how hard fucking Paul Daily Hits and you underestimate how long his arms
are as well. He's got a unique belt. He's wastes like this big, he's like,
he's built like a Dorito and he's got really wide shoulders and really long arm
tall that power's coming from that leverage.
Were you shocked by his fight with Michael Van and page? Um, no, not really.
Uh, you know, I think Paul can be, you know, pull, come,
play the game when he needs to play the game.
He knows when he's taking risks and when he's not. And you know,
there was a lot of law on the line for that and for sure.
But that's the one thing that he always complained about yeah.
Was when guys took him down.
Ego can have a say in these things sometimes though, you know,
and I think a loss is over a bad performances is much worse for Paul when it
comes to MVP. He didn't never heard the last of it.
We occupied the same small bit of land, you know,
you can't go very far in of that, you know,
without hearing about that kind of stuff. He just wanted to get the win. Yeah.
I wonder if, uh, yeah, I see what you're saying.
And I liked that he fought that way.
I liked that anybody fights in the way that they can win because if someone
can't defend that,
I want to know and it's not because I want one person to win over the other
person, even if it's a bad fight. I like when styles clash and you figure out,
oh look at this. If that guy just does that to guess what,
now people know that they could do that to you and other people who were better
at doing that are going to try to do that to you. Yeah. It's interesting.
It makes the sport fascinating for show,
but I would say that Paul didn't get into the fight with the intention of
fighting like that. Right. I think,
I think the take downs where we're a part of his game plan,
but I think he planned on doing a lot more damage on the ground.
That guy is so fucking slippery standing up Michael Van and page,
he's so slippery.
That movement is so crazy to deal with that karate point fighting background.
They are so good at blitzes. Don't feel like you can get close to him.
It feels like he's so far away and if you try to move into the danger zone,
they can get to you before you can get to them and especially Michael Page who
has those long arms and legs and he's so good at keeping his hands down so you
don't know where Shit's coming from too. It's all,
everything's coming from weird angles and the confidence plays in as well
because he's so confident in what he's capable of. He fights loose,
which makes him faster. He hasn't fought since the Lima fight, right? No. Yeah,
that was great. Lima's a murderer.
He might be one of the scariest guys in the 170 pound division across the board
and one FC UFC Lima's one of the scariest guys for sure.
He's boom, boom Alco the lights [inaudible] the fucker. He puts people to sleep,
you know he does is, he's fucked. When he knocked out chorus cough, I was like,
Jesus knocks out to everybody, man.
And his rematch with Rory is going to be very interesting.
I just always worry about rorys nose, you know,
it's always on my mind when he's fighting because they just don't heal.
They just never healed properly. How about Michael Parrots? I Dunno.
How's going to be a long time off? It was on my flight on the way home.
I mean these eyes was like swollen and stuff.
He was out when I'm having a rough time. But yeah,
he but didn't he get surgery while he was in Uruguay? Yeah,
they fixed it while they were there. Oh,
so you left after he had gotten surgery?
I stayed for a day after I get so get some rest. Jet Lag was killing me.
It's good for you. Yeah. How is Uruguay was an interesting, yeah, it was,
it was cool. I mean the fans were great. You know, they uh, they had,
we had one fighter on the card from Uruguay, um, gala, Gloria Eduardo category,
who was, I mean, you just march forward and just tried to, you know,
tried to bring the fight to his opponent. He was fighting Bandon. I, um,
it was backing up, trying to counter strike, but the fans loved it.
In other words, they were rowdy. They were quiet when the fights were going on,
which was kind of weird because they only, they only finds the,
I've experienced to do that or the Japanese funds when, you know,
when the fights going on, they sit quietly, they watch,
they applaud when there's a position change and there was some good fights on
the card as well. The A, the Hallean Piven knee as well from, um, uh,
what's his opponent's name? Bunter in Nigeria.
Bunter and coin with a clean ne and opened him up a lot of stitches. Oh,
I saw that. Yeah. Yeah. And uh, did you Jitsu guy that, uh,
the middleweight guy? Oh yeah. Adolfo Vieira Jesus Christ go good finally.
Yeah, it probably had pallets is good. I'm surprised that, um,
I'm surprised that he didn't press forward more to be honest.
I was expecting to be more aggressive because like via his good,
but he's like five, six fights into his career. You can still,
you can still bully him a little bit because he might be unsure of himself in
the striking a little bit, but he did land a hard job early in the first round.
I think that like woke them up a little bit. Like he's got heavy hands,
but the thing is his squeeze is fucking outrageous. Yeah.
His squeeze is so outrageous. When he wrapped up that head and arm trying,
I was like, you need no one's getting out of that.
Like there's some dudes that do that head in arm choke like that where you see
their back look like a fucking some alien creature when all the striations like,
oh my God, no one's getting out of that. Like you're going to,
he's going to cut your head off. Like that's horrific.
Those guys that have that incredible Jujitsu with incredible physical strength
like the Jack Arrays, Paul Harris. Yeah. Those guys who have the crazies.
You did too, but also ridiculous strength as well are always a scariest. Yeah.
Look at the size of Golden Ryan now in comparison to some flaws.
He's terrifying. Keep Jeff Devinsky way the fat guy.
But that is the thing about Jujitsu is like some of these things have testing
and people do have tested positive and it's been like a huge disgrace.
But the ones that don't have testing these dudes, it's the wild west out there.
They're running rampant.
I remember Jeff Munson turning to that monster walking around like he'd just
been chiseled out him. Yeah. He was goddamn fantastic.
Four character that came to life. Yeah. When Matson was in a [inaudible],
there he is right there. Jacked or the kids jacked. Yeah, I watched him on that.
I'm the beast. Oh, what was it? Uh, a quintet.
I'm in Vegas and he wrote through three guys on that. That is hilarious as well.
He's done Polaris a few times over in the UK. This is just a monster. Well,
it all comes out of that. John, Donna, her, uh, Henzel Gracie school,
what it was Eddie Cummings, John, Donna, her, all those guys. Gary Tonin,
Nikki Ryan, Gordon, Ryan. Those are, that's some of the cream of the crop of,
of young Jujitsu players.
These guys are all savages and I'm really excited that tone is now an MMA.
You know, because he's doing really well and MMA, he's undefeated and he's,
he's fucking people up standing up too. He's getting better at standing up,
but when it goes to the ground, good fucking luck. Good luck.
And I think people would underestimate John Danaher as an MMA coach as well.
You know, the experience that he's had like his, his knowledge of MMA is,
is outstanding. I spent some time talking to him when I was up in Montreal,
Tristar and like the, the way he,
he unpacks things and breaks things down and not only not only breaks them down
for himself to understand,
but for him to be able to communicate that easily to other people,
for them to understand is like,
it takes a special kind of coach to be able to do that. Well, he's a,
he's a really, really interesting human,
like if you just sit down and talk to him,
he's one of the most well thought out people I think I've ever had the pleasure
of having a conversation with.
He just thinks things through and irons out all his points before he ever
expresses them. So when he expresses something to you, it's like,
let me ask you, this is a lunatic. I need to look to take this.
This is an edge to him for sure would never forget him sitting in a club in
Montreal,
like GSPs there and all of his mates and they're all like dressed sharp and
stuff. And they were like talking to the girls.
He had a rash guard on the coast. He did
harassed God potty pack and a pair of shorts and he was just sitting in the
club. Just people don't understand.
John Donner hurts famous for wearing a rash guard to a wedding.
But he's a Savannah as a special individual, you know this, he's,
he's on a different frequency. If you never wore a rash guard to a wedding,
my apologies. But I wouldn't put it bastion. Yeah. Nice. No he did.
I'm sure he did. I'm sure he show that's a true story. I mean, he is a savant.
He's um, what he is his, I think he's senior,
really focused on like transitions and attacks and patterns in Jujitsu and how
to improve upon, uh, various athletes success and games.
And he's created these pathways and these guys that believe in them also
happened to be super dedicated and very talented.
And then you have that entire Hanzo Gracie team,
which is just one of the best lineages of Jujitsu in all of martial arts.
And if you look at what came out of that Henzel Gracie Lee, you know,
you have Matt, Sarah came out of there. Uh, there's,
there's been so many high level competitors and a million different martial arts
organizations. Hanzo is like old school Gracie. I mean he's from the root.
I mean that's the purest uget so you're going to find in the world. So he's got,
it's just,
that's an amazing pool of talent on top of having a wizard like Donna her and
they're fucking with things and fixing things and finding,
finding new pathways and how to, how to counter things and how to,
how to switch things around on people.
And they have a bunch of systems like backtracking systems, leg locking systems,
and it's super, super effective.
And the way he describes it as he's able to cut years out of the learning curve
or these guys by addressing problems that come up before they come up. I mean,
he's proven that though in other speed in which Gordon,
Ryan and Nikki Ryan as well.
Now I want to say Cummings and Gary Tonin and for sure they all learn from each
other for sure.
I mean Eddie is also a big innovator in leg locking and understanding these
systems and innovating and coming up with new entries and new transitions.
All those guys are,
it's like everyone has their own little piece of ingredient that they're putting
into the stew, but the result is really exceptional in terms of success rates.
Like they stood out in a world where everyone's trying to kill everybody with
chokes and armbars and everybody knows chokes and arm bars and they stood out,
but significantly. Yeah. But was, you know,
the thing with Danaher as well as to be able to sit on the mountain,
watch all of those high level guys work against each other,
like he's seeing the patterns across the mat. This, this is,
I wish I'd done this early on in my career. I watched fights as a fan,
but then the further into my career,
the more I was specific about who I watched.
I only wants to watch the fights as I felt like I was going to benefit from
interesting. Whereas now because I watch everything I like,
I see the patterns and I can imagine because Dan has done it on the mat all the
time, watching all of these guys every day,
seeing the patterns in Jujitsu all the time.
They the same positions that get exchanged over and over again and you know the
different outcomes for each one.
And he just seems to have one of those kinds of brains that just absorbed
everything,
adds it into his filtration system and then figures out the more high percentage
stuff and then focuses that as he's as he's syllabus.
And what's really interesting is if he wasn't injured as badly as he is,
I mean he probably would have gone on to compete and maybe not been as good of a
coach. Yes.
That's one of the more amazing pieces to that puzzle. He was a rugby player,
fucked his knee up early. They fixed it, but they didn't fix it right.
And it was always a problem and he was always like kind of leaning on it in a
weird way and it fucked his hip up.
So he had to get a hip replacement and now he's going to get a knee replacement.
And he's a guy known for teaching people how to rip people's legs apart.
It's kind of crazy. Yeah. But he, I mean he's a unique individual though. He's,
yeah.
And I think that is the way that his brain works is his perfect for Jujitsu.
And that's why, you know,
that's why his brain brain is fed so much by Jujitsu and you sit in my,
you see him on the side of the mat, you know,
he's sitting there coaching his guys and it's just,
it's so calm and it's so well delivered and he's,
he always says that full name as well as something else I notice which are not
quite like it, but it stands out. Yeah. Yeah.
I think it's so important to have these unique characters for us or hobbies.
And other ones that have these,
a unique intellectual characters that are involved in their pursuit of people
beating the fuck out of each other. Yeah.
It's very interesting because we've not even seen the crossover of the fighters
that are going to become those people yet either. I mean, you know,
Dwayne Ludwig is a good example of one of the first to really make that
crossover.
Like you look at the way that Ludwick fought and the way that he coaches his
fighters is so very different. He jokes around about it,
but I liked that because that shows the evolution. If I,
when I'm coaching my fighters,
I wouldn't coach them the same way that I used to fight it. You know,
it's got to vary a little bit, right?
Depending upon body size and style and what strengths you come into,
especially in MMA.
But what Wayne Dwayne is doing is sort of like learning what he learned from
everybody, watching everybody but not what he did, which is crazy.
Yeah.
He's obviously teaching you stuff that he knows how to do and stuff that he did
do,
but that style of footwork and switching stances and movement that you see like
TJ employ and a lot of his other students employ.
Like Dwayne's got that like written out.
He's one of those guys that has a real system.
Like if you look at his book you're like, Oh my God, this a crazy person.
It's just like, it's been a great way and a great way.
It's all like he's got everything written out,
like all the combinations and all the movements and all the,
this is not like free for all and just do what feels good. Like no,
he's got like patterns. He's fallen and he puts those patterns on you and you,
you see the success rate from his students learning this thing. He was,
he had a big effect on team Alpha male for the brief amount of time that he was
there. He saw some good results from some of those guys.
He's just uniquely obsessed with teaching people how to strike correctly.
And that's where,
that's where I think there's a very fine line between like programming a fighter
and being a computer programmer. You know,
you get all those systems in place and then that's why like for V as you just
mentioned it and GSP,
they had such a good relationship because it always felt to me a lot for hours
was like sitting in the corner with these, with these control pattern,
just kind of playing the game and because he,
because he'd programmed his fighters so well it was just a, it was pure,
it was a responsive thing.
Same with Matt Hume and a DJ and like obviously there's this some level of
freedom and creativity for the fighter, but they've always got that backup,
that person in the corner that can tell them something and they know exactly
what they mean and they just apply it and it works, you know? And,
and like those, those systems come into play.
And all the codes that are coming in now is, it's interesting,
it's an interest in development I think.
I think that those kinds of fighters will always fall short to the likes of the
Addison years and the and the Anderson Silvers that can play the game inside the
octagon. Like the, the thing like Anderson Silva, the,
I think the most underestimated knockout of his,
and it was a great knockout but still people don't really fully appreciate it
was the veto Belfort front kick to the face because Vito was expecting the low
kick and he brings his shit up to block the low kick as he gets kicked in the
face. And if you watch it from the opposite angle over veto his shoulder,
you can see Anderson's looking at his lead leg like that.
That is so underappreciated cause you,
you don't see those cells from the replays.
You don't see the glances and the looks and the,
the shifts of the body weight and you know the,
the nuances of the fight that when sometimes I'll watch these replaced 10 15
times from different angles and all of a sudden I'll see something and it's like
a light bulb moment. I love those moments.
Yeah.
Anderson had many of those moments in his career where you recognize that he had
seen a pattern and then he just struck on that pattern and hit pay dirt and
you're like, Jesus Christ. Yeah, slap Mike's Holloway does it now
first round. He's like his download round. Yeah, he gathers,
he gathers information,
he studies that patterns and that's why if you look at Mike's Holloway stats,
he's, he's first Roundy's percentage of success is low and his outputs low,
but then as he's success rate increases, so disease output needs ridiculous.
Like I don't know any other fighter that does that.
No, he's brilliant in that and his output is preposterous.
Zau Pit is just so outrageous but not as outrageous as Colby Covington's.
Colby Covington might have the most outrageous output in the sport.
It's outrageous. What about, what about him an Eastman though,
do you think bowls outrageous. It's all who's the better wrestler? Yes.
Who's the better wrestler and who has more power and who can keep that up for
the longest cause Colby can keep that shit up for five rounds.
He's done an amazing job of getting people to dismiss him because they think
he's a piece of shit,
but it's with his and hat and all the trash talk that he does.
It's fucking brilliant man,
because what he's done is just insult everybody in.
Anybody get a lot of people talking about him and then fuck people up.
So it's like, whoa,
this is a crazy combination because it fucks with their head.
They don't want to lose to this guy.
They don't want to hear him talk shit after he beats your ass.
He's gonna Still Talk Shit. Fuck. There's a slight, I don't know,
depending upon the person,
but at least slight burden and experiencing that from a person,
it might be a big burden.
Maybe you're one of those people that has a hard time getting fucked with and
you can't, it keeps you up at night and then it's like a maybe.
Maybe it diminishes your performance 20% maybe 30% yeah,
and Colby doesn't get tired. He keeps coming.
It's terrifying.
Robbie law just kept bobbing and weaving and hoping for these openings that were
never there. And didn't you call me just on you?
He was punching some ridiculous amount,
like one every 2.4 seconds or some crazy shit.
He broke the work rate, right?
Yeah, yeah. Something like that. Against Robbie Lawler. No, but Robbie just,
you know like that first round in particular when he's up against the fence and
he wasn't even hand fighting the chokes like that.
It looked like he was kind of coasting for a couple of rounds with the intention
of getting started later. But then I just, I just think that the,
the intensity of, of Colby, we just burned him out faster than he expected.
I think when you're an explosive guy,
like Robbie is where he fires fucking hurricane speed bombs at you just,
and when he does that,
he's going 100% 100% Colby never goes a hundred percent if you watch him,
he's punching like 70% 60% 70% 60% and he just stays on you,
stays on you. Very Nick Diaz, like in Diaz, early days,
like when Diaz fought frank shamrock, perfect example.
Like he just puts that pace on you,
keeps talking shit and puts that pace on you and he's hitting you a lot so
you're always tight. Like you're always tightening up, tightening up,
and it's just draining your battery. Yeah.
And you don't want to lose this guy cause he's talked so much shit and you're
like, well he's talked so much shit, but when I get ahold of them, guess what?
When you get ahold of him, he's great. That's the problem.
The problem is all those things that fuck with you.
Plus he's a great fighter. So the meanness, the shit-talking,
all the, the MAG staff, the strippers, the CR, the cringe. You're like,
oh my God. Right. And then on top of it,
the fucking output inside the octagon, you're like, shit,
he's doing all that and he's fucking me up.
He might've fucked me up even if he didn't do all that.
But he does all that and I don't want to lose to him and he's fucking me up.
It's like, God damn.
Do you think there's a point where Colby thinks,
you know at any point during his training camp like, Shit,
I've stacked the odds against myself here.
I that moment before Marcus Davis where I thought to myself, if I lose here,
I'm going to like it. I'm going to look really fucking stupid.
I think that Colby is doing a brilliant job of playing a bad guy like pro
wrestling style and I think he didn't use to do that early in his career.
He was a hardworking guy who just went out there and fought his ass off,
but people didn't give a shit and they weren't giving him the credit that he
deserves and so he turned heel and from that he's become the interim
welterweight champion.
He's one of the most talked about guys in the sport he took on a character.
That's what I think and I think that character is super successful at fucking
with people you know mean and he can fucking fight man.
You can't underestimate that. That kind of cardio,
the kind of cardio is crazy to be able to do that for five rounds.
That's bananas that that pace is insane. Yeah.
I'm rubbing Lola's strong as well.
He's just such a difficult person to hold down. I wonder whether,
I wonder where the rubber Lola left some of his training camp in a way,
whether he left some of his effort in the gym.
I would imagine Robbie Lawler is the kind of God it's still trained.
Like he's in his 20s like he's like on it every day. Well maybe.
Or maybe they trained together and when they trained together,
Colby was getting the best of it. I mean,
I think they did train together to American top team, you know,
and maybe Colby knew that he got out, wrestle him.
He knew if just stayed on him, he would break them and out wrestle him. I mean,
when someone has an a wrestling advantage, he goes back to this one more time.
When someone has a wrestling advantage, that is a big deal.
When you start getting tired and this guy has better technique than you and he's
not as tired as you are because he's fighting more efficiently and then he gets
a hold of you and they're like, fuck him on my back. And then you're like,
God damn it. And then you try to get back up but you can't.
And the bell's over and you get back up and you are to keep this guy from taking
me down. Then boom, he takes you down to Dan again.
He keeps punching you on the feet.
He keeps hitting you and making you move backwards and you're just looking at a
land, this big bond,
but there's never an opening for it and you think he's going to slow down,
but he never does. So Colby against Habiba a catch weight. What'd you reckon?
Oh, who outpaces the other one? Dude, they could get Ted Nugent to sing now.
Fuck. Yeah. Um, I think that's a, an amazing fight.
If it could be ever did want to fight it 170,
I think him versus boost mom would also be an amazing fight.
I want to see Colby and new smart. I mean that's the fight, right?
I mean and I also think if you're going to have an interim champion,
you should treat that fighter like it's a champion.
Like you can't just take their fight,
you can't take their belt away if they don't want to fight right now because
they're injured or because they need surgery or I think we have to respect the
championship title. Otherwise people are going to look at interim championships.
Like it doesn't mean anything. It should mean as much as a championship.
Like we're saying you have to fight for the title next.
So to say that they don't have to fight for the title next and we're just going
to take that thing away from you. He's taken away like,
but you're still fighting the person still fight it.
So they're still the champion.
They didn't lose you just take it away because what,
is there a mandatory contender that the WBA the WBC, the IBF?
No it's just the UFC.
The FC decides like who fights and who had fights when I'm happy that they have
interim interim championships. Cause I think there's times and places for that,
but you've got to treat it like it's a championship and Colby never lost the
championship.
He won that interim title against RDA and incredible performance and then they
just take it away from them.
I don't think you need to like the problem is sometimes you've got the champion
defending that belt against another contender and there's an interim champion
that's not available to fight,
but that doesn't mean you have to strip the title from the interim champion.
That's still that still, it's almost like a, it's not a placeholder.
It's like a guarantee that they've got a title shot and their next fight
regardless injured. Yeah. Yeah, I agree. So what, 12 months? Like a normal,
like a normal champion. I just think, you know, in this day and age,
like there's this uh,
attitude that the fighters need to step up and fight even if they're injured.
Like that's not good for anybody. It's not good for the ultimate,
the eventual fight itself, the ultimate product that you're selling the fans.
It's definitely not good for the athletes. This is hard enough as it is.
I think the solution to all this, and I'm a fucking, I'm beating a dead horse.
We're weight classes. I love one weight classes, one weight class,
more champions.
I keep saying this with these no need to move the one 70 weight class.
We can't move that. There's too much history there. You you want to go crazy?
You want to go 55 65 70 no, no, no. I want to say I want to go.
I want to use the old pride weight class,
so we do 55 62 60 twos right in the middle. Who are you?
62 63 that weird number. I'm telling you man. That's the weight class teammate.
Light welterweight. It's right in the middle of the two.
Think of the fighters that we get in that weight class. Mass video could,
could've stopped off there on his way up. Cowboy RDA.
We've got guys that could move down. I would say Covington.
Mike Perry could probably make that weight class and then you know the next
weight class after. That's one 77 that's halfway between the two weight classes.
You're talking madness. I'm making up these crazy numbers. These are,
these are the weight class I'm telling you. And then gasoline stops off.
They're on the way up. Like we were talking about Adolfo Vieira the, uh, the,
the guy that fought the weekend in Uruguay. Yes.
I would say he's not big enough for middleweight,
but I would say too big for welterweight.
And I would say the same about his opponent as he was light heavyweight in the
beginning of his career. Yeah.
But even if you study him next to another middleweight you would be surprised
while he was interviewing Bisbing Bisbing was interviewing him. I was like, wow.
Bisping's quite a bit larger than him. Yeah. He's just filled with muscle.
He's a tank, but you know, so was pro Hi-Rez right? Yeah.
He was pretty fucking effective with that style. Yeah.
I loved the idea of more way classes. I think it's easy to sell fives.
I know, but you know, we're not an idiot. I mean, come on, we can have,
we could have numbers that I don't know about you. Some people are idiots. Um,
I just, I don't like the idea of moving well to weight.
They would just be such a shame to lose that weight class. Oh, that's so silly.
You know, the usual, in the early days, it was one 99 for light heavyweight.
I remember those. When Tito Ortiz first made a debut, it was one 99 yeah.
What was pride? Was that one 90 I don't remember.
It's Dan Henderson was like either side of the line. He won both, right?
Yeah. Dan Anderson that people forgot what a fucking savage he was in pride.
Woo. The monster to took a shot better than anybody that's ever lived. God Damn.
Here it goes. Okay. Submittal weight was a 205 pounds.
Welterweight was 183 pounds. Interesting.
Lightweight one 61 yeah, so those are close.
That's interesting.
Yeah. I fought at one 61 I've fought at one 60 twice.
What do you walk around at right now? I'm light now. I'm like 82 wow. Yeah,
but we're not like I was,
I always start at training camp over 200 pounds when I was at fighting at
welterweight. If you fought and you would want to fight welterweight again.
Right. I bet I'd be open. Yeah. Well to wait, like I,
I could probably make lightweight if I put one time. Yeah, I'd give it a go.
I'd give it a go. How much body fat do you think you would try to lose first?
You would try to lose a lot of body fat first. Get down in the 70s yeah.
I could probably go back, play six pounds. I could lose without, you know,
without me looking unhealthy. Do you eat clean? Yes. Even though,
you know, like not this week I'm not coming to California in and out.
Burger would eat in and out burger last night. Yeah. I'm having a few like,
you know, I'm walking over all ground and having a good, you know,
some memories because a,
I went to the one oh one cafe and [inaudible] we used to go there after the Thai
boxing fights and so yeah, in and out Burger is awesome. Old School. I love it.
But yeah, generally, yes I do. Generally, yes I do. And I tend to eat,
I tend to eat in a small window of time, so like sort of six or eight hours.
And that tends to start later in the day because I'm on a weird sleep cycle
because I mean I'm living in the UK, most of the flights are, you know,
the main card starting at 3:00 AM on a Saturday. And I'm like, you know, so I,
so I stepped to watch the fights and sometimes then I worked for into Sunday,
uh, doing like radio shows and that kind of thing. Stay awake. Yeah,
pretty much. So then my whole week kinda kicks over,
so I'm usually getting up at about noon and then started my start eating at
about six or seven in the evening and I eat for a few hours and then stop train
late at night as well. Um, and why are you in town right now? Why are you in la?
Um, well I'm, I'm here for the fights predominantly. I've got my, uh,
my team in town, my, my youtube guys, the raptors, the, the tills gentleman,
the gentleman, the other surprise me. Then I was like, are you, yeah.
So w we started a youtube channel about three months ago and hit 20,000
subscribers recently, which is all beautiful. What does it tell people?
So basically we're doing, uh, we've got a few different series.
The one I'm working on at the moment is the war room,
which is my breakdowns of the fight. So I do inside the octagon for the UFC,
but because I only do the main events and the European cards,
I get so many messages for the fight. So like for this week,
everybody wanted a Diaz Pettis breakdown and a, a Ramiro Acosta breakdown.
So I've done both of them and they're up. Um,
and this is all you independently correct? This is beautiful. Now d,
Are you allowed to use footage? Yes. The U s here allow me to use, for example.
Cool. Yeah. Thank you very much. Thank you. Thank you for that. I appreciate it.
Excellent. Why wasn't a great, is the thing, I mean,
I'm a UFC ambassador in Europe, so like,
my job is to promote the USC and promote the sport. I've just, um,
I've just taken a job as the head of MMA for UFC gym in Europe as in the UK as
well. Oh excellent. So we've got a load of gyms opening up. Um,
and my own gym obviously is opened up.
And then like the youtube channel was really my main focus cause it's my
ability,
it's my way to communicate directly to the fans cause they're constantly asking
for breakdown. So I can do that. And the raptors are now doing all the
media stuff, so their Creighton vlogs and,
but I mean today I actually feel today I was saying this on the drive over cause
they want it to come over and meet you, big fans of the podcast and everything.
So, uh, I brought the, brought them t show in Vegas as well,
which they blew their mind. Um,
but they were supposed to be at media day to day interview in the fighters,
you know, as part of their job this week. So I said I feel like a,
like a pair and taking them out of school for the day.
Cause when we're done here I'm gonna take 'em to the males, drive through them,
then open up to Malibu and show some, some California views. Yeah,
show him the tour. That's excellent man.
I think you do a fantastic job of breaking down fights.
I always like your analysis of how things are going to go and a one of the,
one of the reasons why I was really excited about you being today is because
this weekend there's, it's a great fight card,
like the Steve a DC DC rematches an amazing car. Amazing fight for that card.
I love the card in general, but the Paula Kosta, UL Romero fight.
That's the one that perplexes me. Like how does that go down?
What happens when these tool fucking Brahma Bulls smash heads in the middle of
the octagon? First of all, it's all time. Best body fight ever, right? Yes.
Oh for sure. Absolutely. They both let the Chisel. That rock is ridiculous.
Like statues of Gods, both of them.
If you're going through options for bodies,
if you could choose like it's flip a coin and these guys getting robbed either
way,
whether it coaster Romero might have an advantage cause he's so freakish,
he's so freakishly built that,
I mean you can't imagine someone having a better bonding. Yeah,
you just have a different body. It's just, it's he, the two of them,
they're look at Yo,
well look at y'all out and right there when he's posing he doesn't even look
real. Jesus Christ. He's such a tough dude. The thing, the difference in the,
in this, in this fight between the two ways that I think,
well we know Ramiro can fight for five rounds and he will take his time early.
But Costa comes out throwing guns. Stress, dangerous man. Wild stress is very,
very, very dangerous. He's got outstanding striking.
He's got real power and he's fast. He's fast and powerful.
The thing is though is he is fast and powerful as Gol and you know,
he's beaten really good guys like Uriah Hall. But this is the cream of the crop.
I mean he's in there against the mother fucker of all motherfuckers at one 85
and you talk about a dude who just can explode on you and send you flying
through the air. Yeah. He ragdolls people. He does peep the shit that people,
when he's wrestling them and you just go, what the fuck?
He jumps at them with shots when he knocked out Luke Rockhold with that left
hand. You're like, what the fuck? Not Shotguns.
And then steps in boom and then kisses them.
Get the fuck out of here man. That's David Goggins and say stole souls.
Yeah, he stole soles is a ridiculous athlete. I'm ridiculous.
My cell is the pilot Costas undefeated mentality might play into it.
Play into Ramirez hands a bit.
Cause cost is going to come crashing forward and Ramiro,
we'll just take his time maybe. And, and Costa has gas,
I mean the guest on the ultimate fighter.
So if he fights hard for a couple of rounds and Ramiro's you know,
I'm still strong in the third. I think he's a different guy now. Uh, really do.
Yeah. I mean, I think,
I think Paul Acosta is at the top of the heap for a real reason now on a lot of
it is dedication while lead Ishmael. Um, that guy was a lunatic.
I love that guy. He's training. He's awesome. Yeah.
And I remember training pride days.
Paula Kosta is working with them and I've talked to me about them and you know
how crazy we'll eat it. She's just like keep making shoes his food.
That's what he kept saying.
He measures his food like that dude has like everything portioned out.
He's just like a hundred percent eyes on the prize. He goes,
that's all he does is train. He goes, this guy doesn't party,
doesn't fuck around. He's just concentrating on measuring his food and training.
So what about the money that Ramirez come into recently trying to change his
mentality? Well, here's the thing, man. I don't know if it's real.
I Dunno if they're ever going to give him that money really to stare down man.
Woo.
But that's the guy not to tangle with security.
Steve read on the right hand side. Steve's a bad motherfucker playing games.
He's got eyes in the dude's eyes like yeah, what the fuck is up?
He saved a couple of shows in Europe that could have gone very good at going
south. I'm sure I have a little story for you from the Gdansk show.
So like I'm standing on stage at the weigh ins,
I'm announcing the fires as they come out. And um, we have a fight on the card.
We have a Polish fighter against the Anthony Hamilton.
And I had the voice come through in my ear saying that that flight wasn't going
to be walking.
So just to drop it off the schedule like during the way and to go in and
immediately I'm thinking that's kind of kind of strange and I'm not sure where
that obviously, you know, some areas of Poland, there's a racial undertone.
I wasn't sure whether it was because Anthony Hamilton was gonna get some heat if
he walks out on stage.
The next thing I've got quite a unique perspective cause I can see down the two
tunnels where the fans walk into the floor.
And I saw this whole bunch of like skinheads with like bomber jackets and boots
just come marching in and they filled the floor space and then they went, oh,
went and sat down in one of the blocks and just sat there waiting for him.
And it was because he was from a rival football from, whoa. Yeah. Oh,
I'd heard about that. Yeah, that's right.
I had heard about that and that's why they cancel the fight. Yeah,
they moved it over to Australia, but like they came around security.
They came through the glass in the, at the arena just,
and if it wasn't for Steve that, that, that whole thing would have gone south.
Like he's the dude.
You imagine if there was a fucking hooligan brawl in the middle of a UFC.
Oh man, that'd be awful. Terrible for the sport. Yeah, that'd be terrible.
Now Steve is a, he's wise man, sees everything.
How do you feel like Romero and Costa plays out if you had a bank on it?
If I gave you 100 bucks, we, hi. What do you see how you see this play out?
I think Costa starts fast and I think he pushes Ramiro back up against the
fence. Ramiro defends it. D you know, covers and covers,
throws couple of shots to push
Costa back. And then I think the second round comes in cost,
it comes crashing forward and Romera catches in with something,
right hook over the top, something like that.
The technique I'm watching out for for Costa,
which is going to be useful for a mirror,
he throws a great body kick to left Hook and Ramirez got this bad habit and you
can see it all the way through the Whitaker fights.
Every time someone throws a kick,
he does this like overdramatized scoop with his arm to like Perry it out of the
way if he's carrying out that the way that body kick is and be wide open for the
left hook. So that's something I'm watching out for with Costa.
I just feel like he's over confidence.
His willingness to take risks and the fact that Ramiro's patient can take his
time is never in a rush to get the knockout because he knows he can get it at
any point in the fight. I feel like his patients might play off on customer.
Mike might walk onto something.
MMM. Imagine if he kaos Costa and we play this over that.
You look like Goddamn here.
But what's most likely happen is that it's going to be completely opposite.
And it wasn't really like was he got a job with the UFC is now the list? Well,
every now and then you're so wrong.
Like when Derek Lewis fought Francis in Ghana, I was like, Holy Shit,
don't go for popcorn.
This has gotta be fucking chaos is going to be fucking chaos.
I was nervous before that five star. I was like, Holy Shit.
Here we go.
I'm like Francis and John was going to be gunning for the title again.
He's going to come out guns blazing.
Derek Lewis goes to war every single God damn time. They're both enormous.
I'm like, fuck, can we go?
Nothing. Yeah. Nothing. Nothing. Nothing.
We working with crews on that night.
There was somebody else who you were working with and they said the woods that
you never say during a heavyweight fire, as soon as it's about to start,
they go, there's no way this is going the distance. Ooh, yeah.
That's a rough thing to say. Was it straight away? And I remember this
well, I was [inaudible] there's no way this is going in the distance. I'm like,
oh, did you put that Voodoo on me? Ricky Bobby.
Oh yeah, that was a, that was a rough one man. But it's,
it's interesting how uh, Francis has bounced back.
France is just nuke and everybody now it's just not mental hump. Yeah.
He had a con right. He had to go through that one fight. You know,
the thing is sometimes we get these fights coming into the UFC and you know,
they're so talented that they're there in the UFC fairly early in their career
before they've had any real lessons,
especially if they've just starched a bunch of guys. They come in at, you know,
10 flights into their career and they've knocked everyone out in the first
round.
There's no real learning process there because they've not found anyone to
challenge them.
So then they get into the UFC and then we get to see them go through that
process in the UFC. And I think that's what we've seen within knew, you know,
took him get into a world title for someone to really show him something in his
game that made him feel vulnerable. And then, you know,
we've watched him go through that process.
Like in the moment it's really annoying because we want to see a mad fight.
But in hindsight you can kind of look at it and go,
well I appreciate that as part of his journey now. And you know,
I understand where he was at. You got to give steeple credit for taking
fucking bombs in that fight. I mean he took bombs in that fight,
especially in that first round all at fuck.
Francis is always in it when he's standing in front of you,
when he's standing in front of you, he's always in it.
But Steve Bay managed to just slide away from most of them.
The ones he got hit with, he went with them, rolled with them.
The ones you got to hit clean with.
He just absorbed and kept going and ground them out.
So here's a question for you then.
Do you think you take punches better if you expect the person to punch hard?
Probably because I would say that he took bigger punches from Ingando in that
fight than that than the punch from DC.
And I would say he was probably more vulnerable to the punch from DC because he
probably wasn't expecting DC to knock him out. Could be, could be,
wouldn't expect to get caught like that in the clinch either.
There was a really perfect utilization of the clench work combined with that
crazy big overhand right.
I mean he really set him up perfectly for that and it was something that
obviously was a part of his repertoire. It was not something that was just, Oh,
it was just having to be there for the moment.
He set him up for that and that that was just a perfect right hand.
And he caught him when he was looking. I mean, he just didn't,
didn't know that punch was common, clipped him, dropped him, put him away.
The real question is what's it going to be like now that he knows that DC can
knock them out and mean? Is he gonna fight from the outside,
try to land big shots. He's gonna avoid the clench at any cost.
Now he's got a big height and reach advantage. Can he keep DC off of him?
And then also when a fighter is,
had a lot of wars, like Kim with junior dos Santos, the first fight,
it was a war, right?
I mean he's had some wars and his career street fight the in Ghana fight true
fight was a war is Scott stopped in that fight.
You know how many the Mark Hunt fight, right?
That was a war CP dominated time from top position as well.
And even the Alistair Overeem fight, I mean that first round was causing chaos.
It was chaos until he wound up stopping him.
How many of those can a fighter have?
How many of those can fighter have before we see them?
Start to fade in front of our eyes and I'm not suggesting that we saw that with
him because he was able to withstand the scariest fucking heavyweight striker in
this sport.
And I think the DC punch was just a punch he didn't see and it was perfect and
it just put them away. Yeah. Would be surprised if it happens again first round.
I'd be surprised if it happens again because I think he's,
he is going to be far more respectful of the fact that DC's got power now for
sure.
I think you're 100% right and let you go back to his UFC debut and like he did
fight long.
Like he used to use the real good lung jab and a low kick and like recently his
is kind of crowded. His work a lot is steps in re close with that right hand,
which often, you know, offered the clinch, the DC,
he's just Kale and so many people that I think that he's like fuck it. You know,
I'm just going to get in there and just bombs away with these people.
I mean makes it exciting. It's,
I think he is the least appreciated successful heavyweight
champion ever. And I don't understand it.
I don't understand that he's got everything. He's a, uh, you know,
he's a firefighter, an active duty firefighter. He's a knockout fighter.
You mean he knocked out for doom moving backwards with a perfectly placed right
hand. He's a fucking animal. I mean,
he fights super exciting. He's been smashing everybody. He stopped,
he won more heavyweight title fights than anyone in history.
He defended the title four fucking times. No one's been able to do that.
That's how crazy that division is and still does not get the respect he
deserves. And He seems pissed off this week as well.
Good luck in his interview diseases. Fighter man, guys. An animal.
Yeah.
He just, he seems annoyed. I just,
I wonder whether that's going to play into the flight because I got the
impression from him that you did not watch the, the previous fight.
I got the impression that you'd not watched the first DC fight. Yeah. So that,
see that concerns because then the idea of,
of what happened in his head might be very different to what actually happened.
Well God, do you really think they would let him not watch that? I don't know.
I don't know. I mean there are some fighters that do, it just blows my mind.
And the way he was talking in an interview was like, like it's, you know,
and the other, the thing,
the thing that concerns me more is that he was talking about how he was winning
that that first round, you know, he felt like he was controlling the fight.
He was, he did a lot of good things until DC caught him.
So if he starts banking on that being, you know,
just one of those punches that he got caught with, he might not, you know,
give DC the credit for, you know, opening that vulnerability up.
Yeah,
I think for sure he must have heard all the different people discuss tactics
though. So it doesn't make any sense to me that he insulates himself that well.
And for sure his coaches over at strong style. They've definitely,
oh they've watched it.
They understand what w so maybe he realized in his coaches,
in their guidance of him during training and he for sure he knows that DC
knocked him out.
So when he's going to do is go in there and fight like he's trying to get it
back. The question is,
is he going to be able to use that Longreach in that height and that power on
the outside and keep TC the fuck away from him cause he's got a considerable
height and reach advantage Kenny stuff, those take downs.
Can he keep DC from getting on top of him? Can,
you know if he can do all those things, he can get very interesting.
And if DC, you know, he's undefeated at heavyweight man.
I mean I think that's really where he shines.
You look at what he did to Josh Barnett fucking throws him to the air like a
ragdoll when he was in the Strikeforce Grand Prix did,
he was a monster at heavyweight, you know, and the wrestling's unparalleled.
Yeah. So do we get Jones at heavyweight then? I hope so. I do. I really do.
I think he wants to do it at light heavyweight though.
I think he wants to prove a point what d c wants to do with La heavyweight. Yes.
I didn't think he wants to lose that weight again.
Those are what I had heard was that he wanted to fight at light heavyweight if
he fights John for a third time. That's what I had heard.
And I think I heard it from him. Huh. And he,
but I would incur if I was in his camp, I'd say, fuck all this dieting, bro.
Like, look, you, you, you know, when you have a belly, you fuck people up.
You know? And he doesn't worry about food.
He doesn't worry about cutting weight. He n he's fast for heavyweight,
much like Andy Ruiz. You know, I think there's a benefit in that. There's,
I mean, obviously people,
there's people that knew that Andy Ruiz was a really talented boxer coming in,
but there's other people that looked at his body and dismissed him.
But when you see the efficiency of those punches,
like and the fact that he's able to uncork so many punches in close.
Whereas Anthony, Joshua, these giant arms is long length,
gets a little bit smothered by that closer distance, closer distance and,
and he's just dropping bombs on him over the top and big power to him to man and
yeah. Perfect. Perfect mechanics. Like so fluid,
everything is just smooth and fluid. Who Fuck knows man.
Maybe DC's the best heavyweight of all time. Yeah,
well I mean quite possibly and there's something to be said for that physique as
well. There's an efficiency that comes with that. You know,
like you look at Anthony, Joshua and yeah,
I mean it looks like a physical specimen but the drawbacks would be obvious over
rounds. Whereas I, you know, Andy Ruiz DC, they can just,
they just keep flowing and you know those punches are more about the,
the momentum, you know,
you need a certain amount of muscle mass to get the movement started and then
you maintain it with good technique. You know,
like an additional amount of muscle is not going to make up for a heavier punch
really.
And he's talked openly about being far stronger in training as a heavyweight
than he was as a light heavyweight. He just felt better. Yeah,
it's weight class. I really do. I think his, you know, look,
he beat the greatest of all time. I mean the greatest on paper of all time.
At least. At least on paper.
I feel like performance wise there was moments where Cain Velasquez was in his
prime while I said like, that's the motherfucker that to me,
I mean I know it doesn't play out on paper because he was injured multiple
times, a gang surgeries. But when he was in his prime man, he was terrifying.
He just didn't stop. He didn't still,
he had welterweight Colby Covington style endurance as a fucking heavyweight
man. He didn't make any sense.
And he's slightly bigger than DC everywhere is until I reach in that I never
attended and you know, and he could fuck you up on the feet too.
I mean he could do everything.
He was so efficient and smooth and just relentless. Relentless. Yeah.
No one more relentless. And Cain Velasquez in his prime for him,
it was almost like his body couldn't handle the strength of his brain.
Like his mental toughness was so incredible,
but he just couldn't keep up with the body just starts blowing.
Cause his mind just press forward, go, go, go.
You know his and his cardio was just preposterous. Didn't make sense. Yeah.
DC looks in good shape for the open workouts yesterday.
I think he's expecting a harder fight this weekend.
You know where we really got robbed that we never saw Fado vs Cain in their
prime. Oh Man. We were robbed.
We were really robbed because who the fuck knows modify that went,
who the fuck knows? Maybe fader would've caught him in an arm bar.
Who the fuck knows? Maybe came with a beat that shit out of him?
Who the fuck knows? We will never know, man. We'll never know.
And now they're both fighting, but it's too late. You know?
It's like they'll never be authentic and you won't be authentic.
Now I never forget that.
Suplex Kevin Randleman [inaudible] and like his face just didn't even change.
Cain Velasquez is doing pro wrestling and he looked good.
He did a lot of wild shit.
Like it wasn't just like he would go out there and fuck around. He had,
they had some serious choreograph shit.
Like he did some crazy flips and like this came from Alaska.
This is a fucking heavyweight restaurant.
Tony Hinchcliffe right now was creaming in his pants like, yes,
this is better than fighting.
So does that mean that most of these injuries came from training camp then?
Amen. Who knows? I think a lot of them must've come from fights too.
It's just the mind that he had that that fucking berzerker mindset,
that just juggernaut mindset. Just he would look, he was dead behind the eyes,
man. It just was coming forward like a fucking shark. He would see him like we,
he's overwhelming Ben Rothwell. You'd see that look on their face.
Like it's very similar to the look in the face.
You see a lot of Khabib's victims. They're like, mother Fucker,
this is never gonna end. What kind of animal is this?
Certain people where it's never gonna end ramen deck has was another guy.
I remember meeting him once and he's same,
just like his eyes were just like,
Jamie loves this movie that he did show up, said, watch this, here's the move.
He jumps up, flips and throws them on the back.
So how can a guy with a bad back through it seems like Jesus called what a
hurricane, hurricane neurono hurts Christ. That's the name of the move.
You jump up and like, ah, get your knees around their head and it's pretty wild.
We going see tiny focus and do that. So you know who's trying to,
Trump didn't like that. Darren Cruickshank go to Darren Crookshanks. Uh,
what is Dan Cruz rising now? He's and say yes. What is his, uh,
Instagram page? Oh, I don't remember. He's like the second coming up dumb fry.
He's talking about that,
but he's practicing this really weird take down defense the other day and I was
wondering if he's actually going to try to use it where someone's diving on to
him and he's drilling this where someone's going in on the leg and he's diving
onto their back and rolling over the top of their back.
He's going like back to back with them and then rolling over the front.
And I was like, wow man, Jeff, he pulls this off like you.
I think nobody would expect that.
I mean maybe they would now that he's put it on fucking Instagram,
but look at the bar that DJ did. Yes. Yes.
I'm surprised with not seeing a few more people attempting to get anybody else
can do it. The sushi roll. The sushi roll. Yeah. Watch.
I mean he's drilling it like unsuccessfully sometimes watch this. Okay.
I mean he's going over the top. He's Christian is doing it with a woman too.
Whenever this his wife or something like that.
Okay.
Cause he's uh, he's being rough on her doing. Boom.
I wouldn't want this big ass hole rolled over my back.
I don't hurt your lower back man. Oh there. See now he's got it smooth.
See this is interesting.
So it does kind of look like he's actually practicing this.
If he ever pulls it off in a fight, that'd be fucking crazy. Yeah.
But he's a really interesting fighter in that he's got a great blend of
traditional martial arts wrestling and like, uh,
like he's got boxing style, but he also has karate style. Is it cure kitchen?
Is that what you started with? Is it because he's got that,
those hips that kind of come up with the side? Trying to remember.
I'm trying to remember what his original style was,
but I know he has a wrestling base too,
but I think it was some branch of karate. I don't remember.
It was Kyokushin though. One of them, yeah.
Showed con Kyokushin is a lot of good stuff in that validation once parents
started with taekwondo, so, oh, talk window. Yeah.
So that kind of martial art, traditional martial arts style,
but with also like good boxing and shit and he's doing really well over and
rising. Yeah. I liked that promotion. I oded some of the gloves.
Did you watch it though? You have to watch it online. Yeah. Watch you online.
Because the good thing with rise in is that usually it starts and when the UFC
just finished, so like I'll have been up all night,
so the prelims will have started at 11 o'clock main cards at 3:00 AM then by six
I'm waiting on the press conference usually,
but then rising start and switch over to horizon. Double Espresso, stay awake,
keep going, write it out, keep going. Did you a,
I mean that's where Kron Gracie started to, right? Yeah. Yeah.
Very interesting seeing him in the UFC and that he is fascinating.
He is a fascinating individual. Just, you know, just to,
he's just got a unique energy of Batson, which you would expect from, you know,
from Hickson's son of course. Yeah. Dude, he's lineage.
They were on a different vibration. They are, I never forget choke.
I used to watch that all the time.
Then the Nale breathing that you used to do the, yeah. Dude,
that's like one of the most legendary martial arts documentaries of all time.
Yeah. Do you remember? Do you remember the one day of Zen Mario Sperry? Yes.
That was lucky too. That was like, it was, it was a day,
it was a day in the life of Mario [inaudible] decided to put one of each of his
training sessions from the whole weekend to the same day.
There were like five different training sessions and by the last two he was just
fucking exhausted.
Like it was quite clear that the tried to fit so much into that one day.
That was fascinating.
And he was using one of those vibrating platforms you remember that?
Cause was he really stuck out in my mind? It was, yeah, it was the one,
it was like a vibrating platform and he had a medicine ball on it and he was
like holding the medicine ball and this vibrating platform and then like
changing positions like scarf hold and like one of that would really help you.
Yeah. I don't know. And then, uh,
Hixon had the elastic around the head until you remember that?
Remember when Mario Sperry started coaching over Blackzilians? No. Yeah.
Mario Sperry like became
like one of the head coaches at Blackzilians for a short period of time and put
on these crazy motivational speeches where everybody got fired up. Really?
It's like God damn. Yeah. And it didn't work out.
I don't know why it didn't work out,
but it was a really exciting development because, uh,
I know Rashad Evans was really excited about having them over there and they
were all, I mean, I don't know what happened behind the scenes,
but I remember when Mario Sperry was like coaching the classes and like getting
everybody fired up. I'm like, Damn. I mean, he's old school,
man. That's crazy. Yup. Constant Gracie legend.
When I was a white belt,
I was training at Carlson Gracie's in on Hawthorne and Mario Sperry.
When he would teach you class, he would teach you a class and you,
I knew who he was. I had watched him fight on television. I knew who he was.
I mean, I was like, this is Mario fucking Sperry.
And Marillo Bustamante would be there and, um, call us by Hato.
Remember all these guys? Yeah. Yeah. Sergio Cohen was there.
All these beasts from the Carlson Gracie hit squad and I'm the guy who teach you
and then after we teach you we said thank you and he's like, no my friend.
Thank you for the pleasure of teaching you. Thank you.
And he really meant and like shake everybody's hand.
The most gracious down to Earth Guy ever. But it was hilarious.
He was talking about how we practice his triangle and his girlfriend.
He's like a, he goes just repetition, repetition, boom, boom, boom.
And my girlfriend like, no I don't want you to do it. It's like shut up,
keep going, keep going, keep going.
It's like talking about like practicing on friends,
like get friends to like let you triangle them over and over again. Yeah.
This is when he had white hair at the time.
So this is UFC two 20 he's training with Vulcan owes to mirror.
I wonder where he's at now cause he was really good at it man.
He was really good at like,
like hyping people up and you know obviously his Jujitsu knowledge is top of the
food chain. Yeah. He was in a bunch of the colon in the early USC scene,
like vetoes Culinar and that kind of thing. I don't remember. I don't remember.
But he's a true legend. You know, he's,
there's a few of those guys and I will sometimes, yeah,
well it's one of those guys from the early days of uh, martial arts that was a,
a real jujitsu master, you know what I mean? He was a real master. Yeah.
Lift in the gym as well. But then,
I mean it was like everything about that life revolved around the gym. Yup.
Like, yeah. Trying to try to find that kind of, that kind of environment. Now,
I mean, Donna has is, we were talking about Henzel Gracie is,
I might imagine not called very similar vibe, you know,
in a basement in New York and ones showing up every day and grind and doing the
same thing. But it's such a rare environment to find yourself in.
Do you remember when Mario Sperry got tapped out by that bad ass Russian dude?
It was the bad ass Russian.
The Russian dude was the same guy that frank shamrock code with a slam trying to
remember amongst Sulu F who? Mario Sperry
looked like. He opened up a couple of gyms called hard knocks. Three 65. Okay.
That's Henry who, okay. Alright. So yeah,
that's where he was originally to um,
Google frank shamrocks mixed martial arts record.
It's frank shamrock. Slam this dude and Kao to him.
And this guy was famous for having beaten Mario Sperry and um,
the old school, what was it called? Battle battle Cade.
I don't remember. I remember extreme fights. Extreme fighting.
That's what it was. Extreme fighting battle Cade.
Cause that was where Ron Peretti's organization,
that was where Conan fought Maurice Smith. So here it is. Go.
Where are we at here? Go back a little low. Hold on. Sub Sub. Sub Sub.
Sub Igor is a Novia. That's illegal. Remember Igor Novias?
He was a beast. Yes. Dangerous Guy.
Well Igor had cut Mario Sperry open.
He wanted a big ass gash as for it.
And Mario wound up tapping and Igor is a Novia was a, I think it was a Samo guy.
Yeah, I remember that guy. Tough motherfucker.
There was some scary dudes that pass through the USA a while back.
I remember there were two, there was from the red devils.
There was Undray seminar and a Massulo F whoa. Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
Wait a when,
when he was Jeffrey up stores and Novia was Jeffrey Epstein Security Guard.
No fucking way. That's right. Oh my God.
Look at his face. That's him. That's crazy dude.
That is crazy.
Former MMA guy gives alarmingly kg interview about working for Jeffrey Epstein.
Click on that.
We've got former shit to look for all the fall alarmingly cagey interview.
Who's, who is this saying? This MMA dash guy.
That's the oats. Deadspin oh, so, um, scroll down a little bit.
Let me see what the fuck you has to sit here.
So that's crazy that we're talking about this guy. Just randomly.
Wow. He said one thing you told me for instance, okay.
One thing you told me is he got a heads up when the authorities were going to
come to his house the night before. He said, and then he says, listen,
what you say is between you and me. Okay, let's, let's fuck.
Let's leave this alone. But anyway,
feel free to Google Ladies and gentlemen. That's crazy.
They were just bringing him up and it turns out he was Jeffrey Epstein Security
Guard. That's crazy. He was a real veteran.
I mean that guy was a, on the early, early days of the John Preddy promotion.
He a beast, man. I'm been getting those video cassettes from, yes,
virgin megastore in town. UFC Two and three Oh man,
I remember when you first started fighting in the UFC. I remember those days.
Yeah, it's crazy. It seems like it was a long time ago, but not really.
Like it still seems like it makes sense. 89 I was in double figures.
Wow.
80 99 and that's the only time I've ever been cut. Believe it or not.
I've never, I've only ever had five stitches. You have someone looks at you,
you're a beautiful man.
They would never imagine you get hit in the face for living single as well.
Now we'll look at that. I know.
I'm ready to make it to 10 I might might've thought face only ever had five
stitches. That's incredible. Yeah. Right. And that was, that was the first my,
my UFC debut could hero Gona hit me with an open palm and it was the seam on the
inside of the [inaudible]. Yeah. Yeah. Going back to the whole idea of Whoa,
people fight bare knuckle. I've sent some ended my thoughts on it.
Just too many cuts. I walked because of really,
because of Chris Levens last cut from Dakota Cochran. He had a giant gap.
Have you seen it? I don't think I have none. It's a rough one. Yeah.
I never really watched the band too much. Chris Lieberman's uh, Instagram page.
I'm looking forward to it developing because I think it will,
I've no problem with it.
I think people should be allowed to do whatever they want,
fight under whatever rules they want, but at the moment it just,
it just looks like that boxing with no gloves on as opposed to bare knuckle
boxing, which I think looks very different. Is there any video at all?
People bare knuckle boxing from the olden days. Look at that picture,
the picture. Dude, that's horrific. I remember when he fought Michael Bisping.
Do you remember? I remember his face after that fight. He,
you sat next to me at the press conference. Like a busted him. Yeah. Yeah.
He's had some tough to tell for his own good Anderson Silva's UFC debut. Ding,
Ding Ding thing. Yeah. Yeah. I remember when he knocked out [inaudible].
Oh yeah, yeah. He lowered Vandelay into a fucking war and Terry Martin as well.
That was a back and forth one. He could kill you man.
And if you want to stand in front of Chris and you wanted to swing wild punches,
he shut your fucking lights out all day. And when he did that, the Vander line,
I was like, well yeah,
but it's like two different,
two entire different styles of fighting until like the Chris Liebing style of
fighting, which we all love in the Anderson Silver fights and style,
which is like witchcraft. I remember I was caged child bender,
I was caged sideway notes that Tony Frickin was that, oh yeah, you were there.
I was there. I went, he fought Lee Murray. I mean,
people don't talk about that fun, but like he just dismantled Lee Marie. Yeah,
he did. Murray was a talent that we lost early. I mean, you know,
made different decisions that led him down a different few unfortunate choices.
But, but yeah, he's dismantled them in that fight. Yeah. What do you got here,
Sam? Right. Uh, that's me. That's me. Yeah.
That was the card that he was on.
But if you can find a photo of him in the press conference afterwards,
he allowed the elephant man. Oh, it was bad pictures. Oh, this is a, yeah,
this was, yeah, UFC debut, right? Yeah. Yeah. There it is.
Like Bisping just 18 off on them. Yeah. Yeah.
That was still 15 minute fights as well. And main events.
So that was only a 15 minute fight. Yeah. Isn't that interesting? Like the fire?
How, what do you think about the five round main event? You liked that? Yeah.
I don't mind it. Even if it was on a championship fight. Yeah. I don't mind it.
I just ate g changes. Boy changes
the, the way that fighters approach to the sport.
I think it changes their output. Yeah.
Like there are some fighters that will go, okay, you want 25 minutes,
I'll just spread out my same workload over 25 instead of 15. Um,
the thing I like about it is that can, it can be far more tactical.
And the one thing that I enjoy about boxing is the fact that you can,
you can implement a narrative in the first round that can play out in the later
rounds and you can,
you can allow it to breathe a bit because you've got 12 segments that are being
scored separately. You can gamble a few and you can play that game.
Whereas in MMA, you, you lose one round, you've got to win too. You know, we're,
so the five rounds you can lose one,
you can even lose two if you're feeling very brave.
And then when the last three, so I don't mind it too much.
I don't mind it too much. Yeah, I think it definitely changes the way you fight,
right? I mean if all boxing matches were like glory fights,
like glory fights,
three rounds for the non title fights and then one on the three minute rounds,
those guys go to war. Yeah.
I mean it's one of the reasons why it's so exciting is because there's such a
high output, high volume because they know there's only three rounds. Yeah.
It's interesting because tactics do get adjusted. You just have to stop faster.
You have to, you know,
you have to do your first two rounds in the dressing room before you walk out.
What do you think about pedis versus dia as this weekend done done?
I honestly, I think I took some stick for this on the youtube,
but took stick stick stick is, that's a British ism is it? Is that shit?
I took a shit stick. Sounds like tick. That doesn't,
no one says that it took some Dick. Yeah, I wouldn't say that again.
I'll adjust.
You know what he was saying would come like I never heard that before.
I'm trying not to nitpick. I'm learning. I'm still loading. So,
uh, what did you think? I think Pettis has got the skills to beat is everywhere.
Really? Yes I do. I think he's, I think he's a,
he's a better striker all around.
I think he's got a higher fight IQ at least what he shows as you've make better
decisions than Diaz does.
I think Diaz realized far too much on his toughness and his and his ego and his
ability to walk through stuff and it works.
Sometimes it works against Michael Johnson. You know,
you got his front leg battered in that fight and just kept marching him down and
eventually forced him into a boxing match and that could happen against Petty's.
There's no doubt about it.
My feeling is that Petty's has got the skills to start setting Diaz up because
Diaz is very predictable. You know, you can kind of,
you can make him walk the directions that you want.
You can make him lean in the ways that you want to lean. If you've got the,
the ability to, you know, to land the strikes that match that matter,
then then you can put them out. And you know,
same thing with Costa having the body kick to the left hook.
I feel like Pettis has got, um, what he used it against Tony Ferguson,
he used it against Michael [inaudible] is a a right body kick to a straight
right. And because Diaz is Southport in the lean,
so heavy on that lead leg block in the body kick and in the straight right might
be something that Pettus is going to be looking for. But I just,
I feel like Diaz is there to be hit and I think he uses that to his advantage
because he kind of homer Simpson's people like you wear yourself out, hit him,
me and then I'll start to push my, my game on you.
But when you about him against
talented strikers, like you brought up Michael Johnson chopped at his leg,
but he wound up beating them up. But the Conor McGregor fight it.
Todd Connor is a very skillful striker and in both fights he wasn't really able
to do much with Nate.
He clipped him a couple times in the second fight and dropped him.
And you know,
there's speculation like did he drop because he got knocked down or did he drop
cause he felt like it was a good enough punch to lay down and have Connor come
and meet him and wrap him up and catch him in something which easily could,
you know, you don't know. I mean he,
part of his strategy might've been tried to lower Connor into following him to
the ground for sure. The doom tried to do that against Mark Hunt Company.
The Times, you know, it takes an over hand falls to the floor.
We did it to fe door. Yeah.
I mean I do feel like Kinda caught him at least a couple of times. Clean and,
and he definitely did. He definitely did.
But then they came back and it was a really close fight at the end.
Really close fight. An excellent fight.
But Conor McGregor is a fucking skillful Stryker and I don't know who would win
Conor McGregor versus Pettis.
But Conor McGregor has proven when the Dustin poor Yay Phi in the Josie Aldo Fi,
he's proven in the Eddie Alvarez fight, he fucking shuts people's lights out.
Was not able to do that to Nate Diaz. So, and I think,
I mean in my perspective you might be underestimating Nate Diaz is a lot slicker
than he appears and he's harder to hit.
He knows how to use his jab and his long left hand.
He's not like the best kicker in the world,
but he's never really had that as a part of his arsenal. But his ground games,
super, super high level, he's tough as shit. His endurance is ridiculous.
I don't like about it. Sold them the rest of mate, any of that.
One thing I will say though is that the difference in the way that the fights is
absorbed punches is different.
So all the people that you mentioned that knocked that,
that got knocked out by McGregor, they were all leaning heavy on their lead leg.
So to me that is like hitting a punch bag that's hanging from the ceiling hits
in Nate Diaz. He's like hitting a bag,
standing on the floor because he's wait is so spread over his base that when you
hit him, you know that let those inflatable standup punch backs,
if you blast that thing into the topic just rocks away and comes back. You know,
it's like, it's like a reed in the wind.
That's how he was able to absorb those shots from McGregor because as they were
coming at him,
he was already moving away and he was able to ride the power and then McGregor
was over extending. You know?
And I mean there's no doubt he's a durable individual.
I'm just saying that your liens on that sometimes too much. Yeah. It's also,
we've seen pedis now at 45 55 and now 70 it's really wild to see.
And you go by that wonder Boy Thompson knockout. It's like, man,
maybe this is weight class. Like if he can do that to Wonderboy,
maybe this is his weight class. Maybe. I mean,
maybe this guy has been just tortured himself, dehydrating himself,
and not fighting like he's capable of, cause his body's always weakened.
Like his number one complaint was when he went down to 45 he was a dead man.
Yeah. You could tell he looked terrible. His body just couldn't do it.
So he goes back up to 55 and like discouraged.
And then on this wild whim takes his fight at 70 against Wonderboy and fucking
superman punches him in the mug and cows him like seeing Wonderboy alcohol for
the first time of the UFC fight and seeing it happen because of Pedis. I mean,
he's gay. He gets tagged again while he's out. He's totally stiff. You're like,
wow. Yeah, it's definitely got power. There's no doubt about tech.
Tyron Woodley couldn't stop him. Nobody else has stopped Wonderboy, have they?
Uh, no, no. I dropped a few times, but not, not stopped.
Smiles of the Dow wasn't able to stop him. Yeah. And then, you know,
maybe you underestimated.
Maybe he wasn't expecting pat just had the power to knock him out. I,
I'm starting to feel that's a thing.
I'm starting to feel like if you're expecting of the power, you're more,
you're more brace to, you know what I mean? Sure. What you shock absorbers on,
you're ready to ready to absorb that. So good argument.
So then we're going to like the other thing,
the other thing to keep in mind is that, you know,
patties at one 70 is the same human that he was at one 45,
but without all the suffering, you know, so it's, it's,
it's finding that right amount of suffering and I think a little bit of stuff
for him, for a weight cut is, is, is good. I liked it.
I always thought about it. I always likened it to the march two battle.
You know, like if I'm, if I'm, uh, you know, the Peloponnesian wars,
I'm picking my sword and shield up.
I'm not stepping out of my house onto the battlefield.
I'm stepping out and walking miles and miles. So that process, that was the,
that was the weight cut for me. You know, the, the walk into the battlefield.
And I enjoyed that. And I think that we saw McGregor at one 70 didn't have that.
You see McGregor on the scales at one 55 or one 45 and he's feral.
Like he's wild. You saw him on the scales at one 70 and he's smiling,
he's rubbing his belly. He's not marched to the battlefield, you know?
And I think there's something in that psychology as well. I like it.
Even if it's a small weight and I've done,
I've done everything from three pounds to 16 pounds and I know how I felt across
the board. How did you feel best about eight.
Eight was good for me because I felt put a little bit back on you feel strong
and big for the way class, but you're not depleted.
Like I w I mean usually I would be back up to like one 84 one 86 when I was fine
at one 17 that was my, that was my good way. Around.
One 84 was comfortable because then I didn't feel too bloated and too slow.
I've been closer to one 90 before and it just didn't suit the way that I fought.
So there's a point of diminishing returns for sure. Yeah.
And did you use ivs during those days?
One time I used an only one time and never, never really.
It was for me, it was always a,
it was quite an internal process because I always cut weight on my own and I
always found it strange that nobody else. Yeah, I always did.
You don't have anybody rubbing your shoulders with a room card? Have you seen,
yeah, I seen that. Oh Man, I, man, it was always a personal thing for me.
So like, you know,
running through the streets of Tokyo with trash bags on or sitting in the corner
of the sauna in my own head,
who's the most ridiculous way cutter you ever saw in terms of volume?
Oh Man. Anthony Johnson for sure. Oh yeah, that's right.
[inaudible] so when I fought him in, in Seattle, he could wait that at Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday night to weigh in on the Friday. And,
and I'm don't know for sure this, but I, from what I understand,
he was two 14 on the night when he rehydrated he looked like a different human
being. Oh my God.
And I remember that from one 70 to two 14 it was ridiculous. He was massive.
And like my whole game plan, cause it this for me, that, and this was,
this was a good lesson for me cause he punked me in this one.
I put all my eggs in one basket. That's the phrase that everyone on the staff.
So I thought if I can trash talk him into, make him wait,
I'll make sure that I can get him tired in the fight.
And then they'll start to wear on him in the,
in the later rounds with my footwork and my movement and I just come off and
knock out Las to call us conduct.
And then I get caught up and I've got Anthony Johnson who's never not knocked
anybody out at welterweight. So immediately I'm thinking to myself,
well first of all, somebody at the USC hates me.
And second of all, I've got to deal with this monster in some way. So I thought,
I thought it's going to be a real fight. He's going to throw power at me.
So if I can at least get him to throw in fatigue himself,
then my window of opportunity will come later in the fight. And the,
the original main event was Tito against Phil, Derek,
Tito against in the Guara and Tito pulled out of the fight injured.
So they put Phil Davis in and immediately I got a message on Twitter from
Anthony Johnson, like DM on Twitter. And he was like,
I can't believe they didn't bump us up to the main event.
We need to steal the show. We need to, you know, like, and we, we were friends,
we used to do signings at to tap out with tap out and stuff all the time.
So we were going back and forth throughout training camp.
This is going to be great. We're going to have a wild fire. We're going to,
you know, just kind of basically Kinda psyching each other up for the fight.
Me coming off a knockout, I'm thinking to myself,
there's no way he's not going to try and knock me out. Right.
So I went into the fight with the full intention that I,
we were just gonna like I was going to have to move around and cover and you
know, try and counter him until he got tired.
Then I was going to take advantage of that.
He hit me with a head kick like early on in the fight and I blocked it.
It didn't knock me out and knocked me down. It knocked me over.
It was just a heavy leg, just like being hit with a tree. Trunk, Bang.
I hit the deck.
Then I think there was a scramble back to the feet and then he took me down and
I dislocated my thumb on that first tape down. And you can see in the fight,
I actually reach over it cause I was in, I had him in, my God,
I reached over and put my thumb back in. Oh and he's still crooked.
Little is still not still not quite right,
but then like he just drowned me with wrestling and I, I had just not,
I had not prepared for that. I put all my eggs in one basket.
It was going to be a counter striking match and I was going to defend these
strikes and I didn't expect him to try and take me down at all. Dude,
I think that wait clause, when you,
when he was cutting down from wearable of 200 to get to one 70,
I think it tired him so badly that we didn't see the real
Anthony Johnson until he went up to light heavyweight, which is so crazy.
Remember he missed weight at 85. A V tore beat him up because no one 90,
70 wade in something like that. Crazy like that.
But I think his next fight after me was a Andrea Loskott heavyweight. Look at,
look at what he looked like at one 70 skeletor and then looking at them at two
30 crazy as a light heavyweight.
He was the scariest because his power was fucking immense.
But he's another guy,
he fought heavyweight in the PFL and fucked up a Andrea Lawsky and now he's a
million pounds. Now we sold, he's so big, man. I saw him in the, uh,
in the lobby of the hotel in Stockholm after 84,
I Alexander Alexander Gustafson after he knocked Gustafson out, um,
when I walked into the lobby of the hotel and he was there taking a few photos
and stuff and I walked up to him and I said, I'm glad you didn't do that to me.
And he shook my hand. He went, I like you though, God for that.
Thank God. Holy Shit. He one,
he's in a perfect example of a guy that when he wasn't depleting his body,
we got to see what he could really do and like the Nogueira fight. Oh my Jesus.
Yeah. He got on his feet with an upper class.
Extraordinary when he knocked out, glow over with one punch. Like, God damn,
this guy is extraordinary.
But it was really interesting when I talked to him when he retired,
he retired in the octagon. He said, I'm an athlete. He goes,
I'm not a fighter because I don't like doing this. I'm just good at it.
I'm like, wow. Like,
how crazy that probably the most dangerous knockout artists in the history of
the light heavyweight division.
I would say that I would say who the fuck's more dangerous than Anthony Rumble
Johnson. Yeah. If he connects on you, the only person that absorbed it was DC.
DC absorbed that head kick. She absorbed a big right hand.
The first fight that sent up scrambling. Yeah.
Ridiculous puncher. Ridiculous. Especially [inaudible] you know,
he's a comfortable weight for him to the Glover fight was stunning.
We never saw go over getting knocked down and then also boom one punch bank out
cold. Yeah. You remember the uh, the,
the knockout that I always remember is the Shane Calling Gonzaga fight cause
that was like a six inch punch. Oh yeah. Gonzaga just folded on the spot.
Didn't k o Jimmy man don't went to oh he did. Yes he did.
He fucks everybody up except DC. DC just had that number.
Takes those shots so well.
It takes some shots so well and his wrestling's is so overwhelming and in that
fight, you know, he just wasn't like physically prepared to do that until,
and it's that same game plan twice. I call it,
I'm calling it the grind cycle. You know what I mean?
You're just trapped in that cycle, puts you against the fence.
He takes you down, he beats you up till you give you his Bible,
strangles you in ice. It's a beautiful thing to watch. She's very, very, yes.
I'm so curious as to whether or not he's going to be able to do that again this
weekend and what he's going to be able to do this weekend and steep bay and
what, what steep bay has for him, what he has,
what he has planned and how he approaches the fight.
Now he's got to know that this is,
it was hard to get this rematch and DC's on his way out.
Dcs publicly saying this might be his last fight. He doesn't know.
And then Dana White is saying reluctantly, I'll,
I'll let you guys fight at light heavyweight.
If you fight John Jones the remaster still they're talking about another fight
other than this fight, which I hate. I never liked that. Yeah.
And he's what a year past is past the date.
He said he was going to retire as well, right? DC I think he said at 40. Right?
Did he sell it? 40. So it's at the end of 2018. You know what?
Don't want to keep bringing up trending around.
It's hard to say no to the chatter that cheek. Hey Man,
I'm an old man. I'm talking about,
I'm talking about getting back in there one more time. You seem to want it for,
um, it seems to be more than just for money for you.
It seems to be something you want to challenge yourself one more time. And,
and for people who don't know,
your career was taken from you in a way that you feel like didn't medically make
sense.
They s they told you to stop fighting because they explained the whole heart
condition thing.
It was, it was in the build. It's the Michael Brown wire on pot. Wolf. Yes. Yes.
I wouldn't tell you which part. Um, yeah, I was,
it was in the building at the Mike Brown fight at the Mike Brown Mike Brown
fight. And because it's California,
they're required to do a bunch of different tests and uh, it just,
it showed up as an irregular heartbeat.
It's like I have a second heart heartbeat.
And so it's another bunch of cells in the heart that produced an electrical
current and it can confuse the heart cause cardiac arrest. It can cause,
you know, electrical issues with the heart. I'd never had any problems,
never had any symptoms of side effects or anything like that.
So basically what they told me is that if I wanted to continue fighting,
I had to have an ablation.
So they had to go into my heart and they had to burn the, the, the,
the cells that were producing the second, uh, electrical cork.
I've never had anything wrong with me. It's so healthy.
I've pushed myself to whatever limits I think I've got. And, um, you know,
I'm hoping to find some more, but I pushed myself,
I know what my heart's capable of and I just, I've never doubted it.
I've never felt like you're known for having good cardio. Yeah. I always pushed,
I always pushed the pace and so I, I just didn't want to have anything done.
They said, they literally said to me,
you can have it done and still fight on the same date.
This was five weeks before the fight.
So it just didn't have it having some five weeks. So how much recovery time? Oh,
practically none. Till they go into the,
into the carotid artery and the femoral artery and they go into the heart.
But Lorenzo sent me out to California. What are they going in there?
I know some, some cables are being broken.
The car goes wrong. Yeah, exactly. And then I ended up being an iron man.
I mean, you want to come out with powers, but Lorenzo sent me out to a,
to Beverly hills to a specialist out there to have more checks done. Um,
and they couldn't find anything, any, any anomalies with my heart. No.
Like additional growth or anything like that. So I just said,
I'm not having anything done.
I went back to the UK and then I was busy for a few years doing the commentary.
But I did go and see a specialist.
I'm a cardiac specialist for athletes and he put me through all the same tests
and he points out what they'd seen and he said that it could,
could've been accentuated because I was in,
I was weight cut and I was in training camp. I was tired, he said,
but ultimately these,
there's nothing in these records that show that you can't fly and you're not
safe to fight. So I have the paperwork now. So four months in,
you saw the test important. I've just got my,
I've just got the option to step back in there.
I would like one more because I never felt like I showed what I'm fully capable
of. [inaudible] I spoke at a spa regularly. I dropped in the gym cause I've got,
I've got guys that are training for fights.
So we've had Terry brasier fight and recently out of Mama Singer, um,
Dean Truman fought recently. So I've been in them moving around with those guys.
And you've never really gotten out of training, training,
you've always trained martial arts this whole time, right? Yeah.
And I've always stayed healthy. I never gained any,
I actually lost weight after I stopped fighting because you know, my,
my diet changed. I didn't feel the need to be constantly eating all the time.
So I just,
I allowed my body just to kind of figure out where it wants to be naturally.
One 82 one 84 was perfect for me. Um,
so my plan is just to kind of get to about 85% condition and just sit there and
then like, I mean this weekend is a great example. If like, you know,
Petty's or Diaz fell out and there's no one else around,
that's the kind of place I'll just throw my name in the hat and just to be
available and one of those flights will be perfect for me. Just a, you know,
one of the veterans of the game,
someone that's like not too concerned with the rankings or anything like that,
dropping their, have a great fight.
And then step back out again and just be able to, how you'd like to approach it.
You want to immediately jump back in and fight someone with a big name? Oh,
for sure. I wouldn't, I wouldn't want to cause I might be one more fight.
I want someone to one more. Well that's it.
I want someone that everyone knows that if you love it though, wow,
I would know. I would love it. But I feel very,
I feel very selfish thinking about fighting again anyway because it's not there.
What I've realized since I've been fighting is it's not just me coming out of
retirement. It's like my whole family. I was, I was there,
I was there when [inaudible] got knocked out in London.
I was there when going to Nelson got knocked out in, in Glasgow.
I see the reactions of their family.
I know what I put my family through and because I've had time to kind of step
back and like allow them some time to, you know, the,
the souls aren't as calcified to the idea of me fighting anymore, you know?
So it's a serious conversation to have. But I mean, the reality is like, and,
and you know, the sport's very different now.
Everything's changed. Like when I was fighting GSP,
the conversations I was having with the media was, you know,
what we are and aren't allowed to do, you know, what's legal, what's illegal.
So it wasn't really about about why I was doing it. It was about,
I was basically being an ambassador for the sport while I was in training camp.
So now it would, it would be far more of a, um, an internal journey.
I'd be able to, to really embrace it a lot more and focus on myself. Um,
you know, and now I've got, you know, my, my camera guys,
I'd like to document the process.
I'd like to be able to speak quite candidly to the camera and just bank a load
of stuff. So after the fight, I've got all this,
all this footsies that I can put into something to kind of
give some insight into the,
the mentality of the fighter and the ups and downs of training company. Because
you know,
the days you show up to media day to the press conference and you're like,
you know, you, you,
you're confident in the stage and you shit talking to your opponent and you
smiling and stuff like you might get back to your dressing room and you might be
exhausted. You might feel like shit, you might,
you might have been playing a game for a particular reason and there's a,
there's a good reason you're playing that game.
And I think that a lot of those narratives go on told because the sport moves so
quickly.
And I think I might be able to give like a nice little insight into that.
So if we are going to expect this,
how much time do you think you need to fully prepare?
Where are you at right now? Uh, I always work on percentages.
I would say physically in con I would say I'm about,
I don't know about 58% condition. 58 that's an interesting number. Yes.
Choose that. Well because I'm working through a couple of injuries,
I've not been doing a lot of hands on stuff.
I've been doing a lot of training on my own. I'm starting to build up my,
my aerobic base again. But the one thing I've noticed is, and like, um,
I smoked most days, like my conditioning like always is, is good.
Like I can just get out and run 10 miles and feel comfortable with it and that's
never changed. So all I, all I need to do is just kinda just Kinda test that,
that the toughness in that condition now and push it, you know, to the,
to the points where I feel uncomfortable. How old, you know, 37 done, done.
But I've, you know, healthy, I've not, you know, I'm not drinking 20 years.
I've had ibuprofen since 2009 you know, I just, I, I have nothing.
And you've been out of competition for how many years now?
It's been seven years now. I haven't, yeah,
I told you I work in cycles and cycles. This is my, this,
this seven year cycle. Yeah. Listen, man, I hope you do it.
I hope you fulfill your vision quest like Matthew Modine, that movie.
Thanks man. Fucking do it. I wouldn't be beautiful to see and, uh,
we gotta do this more often, man. Fun. I really enjoyed this. Thanks man.
It's always good. So I'll consider it. It's just, you know,
I live so far away now and I'm in the UK. Anytime you're here,
anytime we're around, I bring a mobile thing. We'll figure it out on the road.
Okay. But have you ever at UFC events? Okay. Thank you brother.
I appreciate you making silicon c Dan Hardy, ladies and gentlemen,
Goodbye.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].